la séance est reprise nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi de
financement rectificative la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 dont le Sénat est
saisi en application l'article 47 1
alinéa 2 de la Constitution dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement 36,77 au sein de
l'article 10
article 10
j'en prends un seul non ah bon pardon
tout de suite attendez alors un rappel
le règlement de Monsieur dessus
pardon
oui les prises de parole sont faites oui
merci monsieur le Président sur la base
de l'article évidemment 44-3 la
Constitution ainsi que notre article 42
l'article de notre règlement qui sont
deux articles qui rentrent en collision
ce soir et à la reprise de la séance je
trouvais utile d'éclairer le public qui
nous regarde sur ce qui vient de se
passer avant c'est-à-dire que le
rapporteur et le ministre vient de
donner leur avis sur nos prises de
parole et nous ne pouvons y répondre
certains d'entre nous aurait aimé y
répondre mais depuis hier nous étudions
les articles du projet de loi
notamment ceux qui permettent dans
l'atténuer la brutalité mais nous ne
pouvons pas les débattre sereinement et
pourtant la gauche et les écologistes
ont des choses à dire sur ces articles
mais nous avons été contraints
aujourd'hui à grâce à l'article 44 3
donne pas pouvoir y répondre et
le volume des articles des amendements
portant n'avait rien d'un surmontable
pour notre hémicycle mais on a bien vu
qu'après les mobilisations massives la
fébrilité vous a gagné et vous a fait
paniquer et évidemment on sait pourquoi
c'est parce que c'est le débat
parlementaire qui a permis notamment à
l'Assemblée nationale même dans le
contexte où ça s'est passé de mettre en
lumière la supercherie et les enfumages
du ministre et de la Réforme et oui
c'est bien le débat le débat
c'est-à-dire des interventions du
ministre les nôtres en réponse qui
permet de mettre en lumière ces
supercheries et sur les 1200 euros ça a
été particulièrement
utile d'avoir ce débat et en raison des
articles que j'ai cités en début de ce
rappel les droits d'expression et de
débats des sénateurs ont été contraints
concassées écrasés et le ministre n'a
aucun intérêt évidemment à ce qu'on
demande ses mensonges donc il a
contraint le débat il s'est réfugié
derrière cette constitution et nous ne
pouvons plus lui répondre
nous continuerons de présenter
évidemment nos amendements sans pouvoir
ensuite les défendre et lui laisser la
parole
j'ai pas fini il vous reste 5 secondes
et bah très bien le débat s'arrête ici
évidemment au Sénat puisque il n'est
plus que dans la prise de parole unique
il continuera dans la rue demain nous y
seront terminé monsieur dessus merci
36,77 Madame pensé Monge
allez
merci monsieur le Président alors je
vais citer une phrase conformément à
l'engagement présidentiel le
gouvernement souhaite procéder à une
revalorisation significative de la
pension minimale afin que les salariés
ils ont effectué une carrière
complètement cotisée sur la base d'un
SMIC bref vous connaissez la promesse
paraît-il l'objectif fiché par le
gouvernement un milieu de ça cet article
en lui-même ne garantit en rien une
retraite une retraite minimum
contributive de 1200 euros par mois
après plusieurs rebondissements entre
annonce flou et René de ministre
notamment le ministre du Travail travail
d'enquête du député socialiste Jérôme
gaz light de lettres rectificatif du
ministre Olivier du CEP il s'avère que
les chiffrages annoncés sont loin très
loin de la portée réelle que pourrait
avoir l'article en effet ce serait
seulement 10000 à 20000 nouveaux
retraités sur sur 800
000 par génération qui atteindrait les
brut de pension uniquement 250 000 parmi
les retraités actuels soient 1,5% selon
la fourchette d'estimation basse ou
autre ce serait respectivement 10 ou 20%
qui seraient concernés mais par une
revalorisation de 0 à 100 euros par mois
enfin il resterait 4,75 millions de
retraités sous le seuil de 1200 euros et
dans ces dans ces retraités
essentiellement des femmes en raison du
caractère mensongé et de l'imposture que
cet article représente le groupe appelle
à l'instauration d'un véritable minimum
contributif à hauteur de 100% du SMIC à
taux plein et porte cet amendement qui
vise à supprimer l'article 10 du présent
projet de loi j'ai pas oublié de dire
que le SMIC pour l'avoir il fallait être
à temps plein ce n'est jamais dit c'est
à temps plein c'est à taux plein et à
temps plein voilà c'est pas la même
chose merci
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
c'est le Président c'est une demande de
suppression de l'article 10 ce serait
quand même dommage de priver ces
retraités d'un minimum de pension au
moins donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
bien sûr nous donnerons pas un avis
favorable pour rappeler que l'article 10
augmente quand même de façon
significative les minimum de pension et
bien sûr notamment celles et ceux qui
ont un taux plein et qui peuvent arriver
à l'issue d'une carrière complète au
SMIC avec l'ensemble des trimestres
cotisés ou pour certains réputés cotisés
arriver à bénéficier de 1200 euros il
n'empêche que un certain nombre de
personnes sont prises dans le dispositif
et notamment de façon plus spécifique
celles et ceux qui ont rompent dans le
dispositif du minimum contributifs
majoré un élément particulier pour les
retraites agricoles qui ont été prises
et qui nécessiteront là aussi une valeur
une revalorisation en fonction non plus
de l'inflation comme la revalorisation
classique des retraites mais en fonction
de du SMIC de même et il a été repris et
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir
effectivement être attentif à cela Retif
repris en ce qui concerne le monde
agricole par une revalorisation des PMR
là aussi au SMIC et non pas par rapport
à l'inflation et vous ne donnerez votre
point de vue par rapport à cela
donc c'est un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons
monsieur le Président et je précise la
demande de Monsieur le Rapporteur que
nous avons effectivement retenu un
amendement permettant d'indexer la
prestation minimum de retraite pour le
monde agricole c'est le 25 66
25 66 monsieur Lurel
attendez
il s'agit par cet amendement de
préciser que la vie annuelle rendue par
le comité de suivi des retraites
sur l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
analyse particulièrement la situation
dans les outre-mer et en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
j'estime que c'est l'un des angles morts
du projet de loi on n'a pas suffisamment
tenu compte des réalités là-bas qu'il
faille appliquer le même texte j'entends
ça et je suis moi assez heureux de voir
que ce que nous avions fait pour le
seuil de récupération sera tout à
l'heure généralisée à toute la nation
c'est bien mais lorsque l'on sait et que
la villa est beaucoup plus chère
les salaires et notamment de la fonction
publique ont été pendant très longtemps
inférieurs
à se pratiquer ici et que lorsque on met
tout ça au numérateur pour calculer le
stade l'air annuellement
ou sur les 25 dernières années ça donne
forcément des salaires annuel moyen
inférieur à la moyenne nationale quand
on sait par ailleurs que pour obtenir le
minimum contributif il faut s'en vain
trimestres là-bas la moyenne partout
dans les outre-mer ça n'atteint pas 110
trimestre normalement c'est plutôt son
donc voilà nous dire que il faut un
volet outre-mer et je serais heureux que
le minus puisse nourrir puisqu'il a émis
jeudi dernier en disant mais puisque
vous partez déjà 65 ans 67 ans ça n'a
pas de conséquences sur vous donc il se
cristallise la précarité et si j'osais
la pauvreté telle que on les connaît
là-bas voilà donc l'objet de cet
abonnement merci
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président pour
effectivement répondre sur plusieurs
amendements là qui vont concerner les
travaux du corps du comité des
réglementations des retraites pour
prendre en compte un certain nombre de
dispositifs je pense que le corps n'a
pas attendu que nous prenions ces
dispositions dans le cadre législatif il
a des missions bien spécifiques qui font
en sorte qu'ils essayent de prévoir un
certain nombre de choses bien entendu on
a vu que ces prévisions ce qu'il en
était d'ailleurs c'était largement
commenté sur tous ces banques et
effectivement elle rentre en compte
notamment
la politique mais les différences de
salaires hommes femmes la prise en
compte des différents niveaux mais
également monsieur Lurel les différences
qui peut y avoir selon les territoires
notamment l'outre-mer donc votre
amendement je donnerai un avis
défavorable parce qu'il est satisfait
les travaux du corps peuvent amener
véritablement une image complètement
différenciée et tenant compte de cette
spécificité notamment
monsieur le ministre merci le 2154
monsieur le rapporteur
rédactionnel
monsieur le ministre favorable cinq
amendements discussion commune le 2229
monsieur Lurel
merci monsieur le Président j'avoue que
je regrette le silence du ministre
puisque mes restes gravé dans la tête sa
réponse qui consiste à dire vous êtes
déjà pauvre est pauvre et que cette
loi-là ne portera pas conséquence
puisque l'âge moyen de départ c'est
64,765 ans et on a un nombre important
de gens qui sont à 67 ans en attendant
l'âge et beaucoup qui sont encore à 70
ans au RSA parce qu'ils n'ont pas
liquidé leur retraite dire ça et dire
que le corps en a tenu compte je me
permets de dire à notre rapporteur que
ce n'est pas juste ce n'est pas vrai le
corps analyse de manière un peu
macroéconomique et macro globale ce qui
se fait mais il n'y a pas de focus sur
les outre-mer on le sait ça quand il y a
20% de retraités ici dans l'Hexagone qui
partent en retraite anticipée c'est 1%
en Guadeloupe un poussin en Martinique
2% à la réunion des critères de
pénibilité ne jouent pas on le sait et
c'est vrai que le SMIC par exemple a été
très différent pendant longtemps les
allocations familiales très différents
même si ça n'entre pas dans le calcul
c'est toujours le cas pour certains
critères sur le logement il y a des
différences institutionnalisées et qu'on
a incorporé ces choses dire de manière
institutionnelle et on veut pas en tenir
compte et le pire c'est que on vous
oppose un silence que à la limite on
peut estimer un peu méprisant de nous
dire oui on fait un rapport ou alors on
va en tenir compte ou alors peut-être
par décret même si on n'aime pas ça on
pourrait le faire j'avoue que je suis
assez étonné de cette affaire là on
cristallise on minéralise si j'ose dire
les inégalités qui existent comme si ça
n'existait pas comme si c'était pas des
Français et j'avoue que je suis assez
surpris par cette attitude de mépris
merci
identique le 2564 madame Mallet
oui merci monsieur le Président c'était
effectivement la même demande de rapport
portée par la sénatrice Dada donc il est
défendu
identique également le 2578 madame Lubin
a pardon madame le haut et vous merci
monsieur le Président alors c'est un
amendement qui est proposé par notre
collègue victoire jasmin et qui demande
que le comité de suivi des retraites
chargés de rendre un avis annuel et
public
accorde une place spécifique aux
problématiques ultramarines en vue de
réduire les inégalités dans l'Hexagone
en effet si de nombreux paramètres
portent atteinte aux calculs du menton
du montant des pensions de retraite des
salariés et travailleurs
ultramarins certaines modalités
spécifiques aux outre-mer concourent
fortement à des disparités de niveau de
pension entre Français qu'ils aient pu
cotiser en France hexagonale ou dans les
territoires ultramarins le montant du
SMIC
le sénateur lui réel a pu le dire dans
les outre-mer n'a pas toujours été égal
au montant du SMIC de la France
hexagonale le niveau et le traitement
des cotisations des artisans et
commerçants par exemple ont également
été différents à la Réunion le SMIC n'a
été aligné sur le montant national qu'en
1996 et par ailleurs
le même sens que mon collègue Lucas
également qui m'a précédé vous savez
qu'il a été ministre de l'Outre-mer et
qu'il a porté une loi qui s'appelle
égalité réelle en outre-mer sous
François Hollande vous voyez c'est tout
près là il y a quelques années tellement
pour vous dire que le décrochage et
sévère
la sécurité sociale censée s'appliquer
des la départementalisation obtenue
après un long combat en 1946 a commencé
à frétiller dans les années 80 sous
Lionel Jospin et au moment où je vous
parle il y a toujours des inégalités
d'applications qui demeure cela donne
des retraités pauvres vous savez
pourquoi moyenne de retraite 541 euros
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est les
chiffres je pense que le ministre on
dispose c'est pas moi qui dit non plus
que partir à la retraite chez nous c'est
généralement avec 110 trimestre validé
pourquoi l'application des lois sociales
a pris tellement de temps a été
tellement a été tellement poussiéreux
que beaucoup de gens ne pouvaient pas
souscrire à cette à ce dispositif comme
beaucoup de patrons échappaient à ces
dispositifs résultat quand cassés parce
qu'on part à 65,3 ans chez nous pas 62
ni 63 ni 64 ni 65 donc j'ai presque
envie de dire que voter la retraite à 64
pour nous c'est une aubaine mais enfin
et bien ça va demander deux années de
plus ça va demander à nos travailleurs
de sa vie de plus c'est-à-dire les
pousser jusqu'à 67 ans c'est ça la
réalité et qu'est-ce qu'on demande au
travers de ces amendements on demande
pas la lune on demande pas l'impossible
on me demande simplement qu'il y ait un
point qui soit fait par le corps et
qu'on puisse analyser réellement la
situation des travailleurs de
l'outre-mer c'est une montagne à
déplacer ça c'est demander la lune c'est
la mer à boire
voilà les sauces mon amendement merci
la parole pour 3941 Madame la
présentation
ah non pardon
créer en 2014 le comité de suivi des
retraites et notamment chargé de rendre
chaque année un avis public portant sur
les objectifs financiers et les
objectifs d'équité à signer au système
de retraite s'il considère que le
système s'éloigne de façon significative
de ces objectifs le CSR adresse des
recommandations au gouvernement au
Parlement régime de retraite sur la base
de ces recommandations le gouvernement
consulte les partenaires sociaux puis
présente au Parlement les suites qui
l'entendent donner à ces propositions
chacun connaît ici la situation des
Outre-mer qui se caractérise par des
inégalités de revenus nettement plus
marquées que dans l'Hexagone une étude
réalisée par l'INSEE en juillet 2022 a
même été intitulé de façon éloquente la
grande pauvreté bien plus fréquente et
bien plus intense dans les territoires
dans les départements d'outre-mer ainsi
9 à 15% des retraités des
départements et sont en situation de
grande pauvreté contre 1% moyenne en
France métropolitaine la pension des
retraités y est en moyenne inférieure de
10 à 17%, si l'on se réfère aux données
2021 de la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse et 2020 de l'agirco par
exemple à la Réunion pour 50 % des
retraités les pensions de retraite sont
inférieurs à 850 euros brut par mois en
Guyane les pensions mensuelles moyennes
s'élèvent à 663 euros à Mayotte elles
sont en moyenne de 282 euros et
atteignent difficilement
617 euros au titre d'une carrière
complète je pourrais également évoquer
le fait qu'à notre mère les
fonctionnaires bénéficient d'une
surémération justifiée par le
différentiel de coût de vie par rapport
à l'Hexagone pourtant cette majoration
n'est pas non plus prise en compte dans
le calcul des pensions de retraite au
regard de tous ces éléments nous par cet
amendement nous proposons
d'élargir la palette des indicateurs de
suivi du CSR pour une prise en compte à
part entière et spécifique des éléments
structurels et conjoncturels que je
vienne citer et caractérisant les
territoires d'outre-mer merci sous
amendement 4959 madame Lubin
oui monsieur le Président il serait
peut-être en effet bon de demander alors
c'est plutôt le corps à mon avis que le
que le CSR
de de faire une étude spécifique sur
les effets de de
la crise sur la situation au regard de
l'emploi et des retraites dans les
outre-mer le corps fait énormément
d'enquête et de travaux donc je pense
qu'il est pas il ne serait pas anormal
de de lui demander un sujet spécifique
sur sur les outre-mer
merci
avis de la commission
et bien clarifier le débat c'est plus un
sujet du corps que du comité de suivi
des retraites il y en a un qui fait le
diagnostic le taux de traitement donc
bien sûr avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président la vie des
favorable sinon le gouvernement aurait
mis ses amendements dans la liste de ce
qu'il souhaite soumettre votre unique de
votre assemblée deux réflexions
cependant ou de remarques d'abord pour
dire à Madame Concorde que j'entends
votre demande madame mais que le
rapporteur a raison ça n'est pas le CSR
le plus à même de mener d'une telle
étude c'est le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites et c'est un engagement que je
prends devant vous je le saisirai de la
situation spécifique des outre-mer et la
deuxième remarque que je vais faire et
qui fait quoi à la fois votre
intervention à celle du ministre URL
concerne le niveau des pensions et là je
de départ en outre-mer personne ne se
félicite que les assurés partent plus
tard en outre-mer pourquoi est-ce qu'il
parle plus tard alors que l'âge légal
est aujourd'hui à 62 ans parce que leur
carrière est incomplète et pourquoi elle
est incomplète parce qu'il y a plus de
précarité économiques de difficultés
sociales mais aussi vous l'avez dit
Madame des systèmes déclaratifs et des
systèmes d'obligation d'affiliation qui
sont plus récents l'exemple le plus
frappant est un Mayotte ou un Mayotte le
système obligatoire pour le seul régime
de base a été créé en 1987 et à Mayotte
les assurés qui bénéficient d'une
pension affiche en moyenne une carrière
quotidisée de 9 années ce qui explique
le niveau très faible de pension ce qui
nuit et ce qui pousse à travailler plus
longtemps les assurants d'outre-mer ça
n'est pas la question de l'âge c'est la
question de la durée de cotisation et
notamment le passage de 42 à 43 ans
parce que pour avoir une carrière
complète c'est la borne de ton qu'il
doit atteindre et pour l'atteindre et
dépasse aujourd'hui largement les 72 ans
et demain malheureusement avec les
chiffres que nous avons ils seront sauf
amélioration économique que tout le
monde souhaite ils seront toujours au
dessus de 64 ans
j'ai déjà dit le président de la
recherche a redit que la Conférence des
Présidents a clairement fait savoir
qu'il n'y avait pas systématiquement de
rappeler réglement j'ai donné un rappel
réglement tout à l'heure à Monsieur
dossu je n'irai pas plus loin pour le
moment
non mais vous ne pouvez pas faire de
rappel au Règlement sur des déclarations
ça c'est une réponse non je suis désolé
on continue merci de veiller à ce que la
séance se passe correctement non non non
la Conférence des Présidents l'a décidé
merci de ne pas revenir là-dessus non
non non
merci merci
non il n'y a pas de prochain rappel à
quelle heure il y a une
non ne mettez pas pardon de vous dire
c'est encore moi qui est la police de
cette séance il a Conférence des
Présidents la Conférence des Présidents
a pris une décision vous la respectez
vous la respectez non monsieur dessus
vous avez eu un rappel au règlement tout
à l'heure vous et ben non
non allez je continue
s'il y a des éléments non non s'il y a
des éléments sur la suite de
l'organisation l'organisation
mais non
vous ne pouvez pas dans un rappel au
règlement répondre à la déclaration du
ministre c'est pas l'organisation des
travaux je suis désolé non non non et
non non allez
l'amendement 3949
madame la Présidente Rossignol vous
imitez pas aussi enfin
Monsieur là il est attendez laissé
parler d'abord monsieur Laennec je vous
donnerai madame la Présidente si c'est
sur l'organisation des travaux
si vous parlez tous en même temps je
peux pas
non monsieur laelec et puis ensuite la
présidente rossignols non sur une
réponse au ministre c'est nous ça n'est
pas conforme non non si c'est sur
l'organisation des travaux j'en prends
deux
non vous venez de dire que vous lui
répondre au ministre
bah écoutez
donc commencez pas allez on va pas
refaire le bazar de ce matin s'il vous
plaît non alors d'abord la présidente
Rossignol cela élève je suis désolé on
attend une minute la présente Rossignol
et puis un rappel au règlement venant du
groupe écolo sur l'organisation des
travaux je dis bien organisation des
travaux et pas réponse au ministre
d'accord d'accord et après on reprend
les amendements
c'est vraiment vous avez un combien
c'est sur l'organisation des travaux
vous savez qu'on n'est pas tous
coutumier et praticien régulier de cet
article 44-3 donc on découvre heure par
heure comment ça se comment ça se
pratique alors j'ai une question qui
concerne le nombre d'amendements qu'il
reste encore à examiner parce que il y a
un instant bon maintenant on voit plus
parce qu'il y a plus de dérouleur en me
voyait moi
mais
ça vous intéresse vous allez voir ça
intéresse tout le monde allez-y madame
il y avait un chiffre qui était là le
chiffre qui est là n'est pas le même
chiffre qui est là et vraiment je sais à
quel point c'est compliqué pour la
séance de gérer tout ça il y a aucune
critique aucune suspicion et du tout
est-ce qu'on peut nous dire nonobstant
les amendements qui vont être retirés
qui entraîneront probablement faire
tomber des sous amendements à cet
instant précis combien nous avons encore
d'amendements sur lesquels il faudra
nous exprimer en 61
871 d'accord 61 voilà 861 non pas 361
il en reste 861 oui oui 861 a présenté
c'est parfait madame la Présidente
Monsieur Dantec oui ils intervient au
titre de l'article 42 9 de notre
règlement monsieur le ministre vient de
dire si jamais nous avions trouvé
l'amendement proposé intéressant nous
aurions mis dans notre liste
pourquoi croyez-vous que nous sommes en
train de présenter l'ensemble de ces
amendements l'esprit aujourd'hui y
compris de la constitution de la
présentation des amendements c'est
justement de dire que si cette
présentation des amendements est
pertinentes le gouvernement peut changer
d'avis sinon on fait ça strictement pour
rien strictement pour rien ça n'est pas
l'esprit de la Constitution si on a
laissé effectivement le droit de
présenter l'ensemble des des amendements
c'est justement pour laisser au
gouvernement une marge de manœuvre pour
dire bah finalement ça c'était pas si
con on peut changer d'avis et le
gouvernement a le droit de rentrer dans
sa liste à la fin d'autres amendements
qu'il a trouvé pertinents monsieur le
ministre dans ce qu'il a dit refuse
finalement l'esprit même de la
Constitution c'est extrêmement
problématique et donc je fais bien un
rappel au règlement par rapport à
l'essence même de l'esprit de la
Constitution que monsieur le ministre
n'a pas l'air d'avoir bien compris merci
allez maintenant reviens aux amendements
monsieur laelec monsieur laelec je vous
en prie merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement m'a été inspiré par une
situation concrète la situation concrète
d'annonc salarié agricole
c'est en trouvant trouvé en situation
d'invalidité dans les trois mois qui ont
précédé l'âge anniversaire de ses 60 ans
et qui par conséquent a bénéficié d'une
retraite à l'âge de 60 ans
l'article 10 prévoit entre autres que
d'assouplir les dispositions
différentielles parce que la personne
que je citais à l'instant ne bénéficie
pas donc de la plénitude des droits se
rapportant aux lois Chassaignes alors
monsieur le ministre
vous aviez pris date
avec moi
ici en séance au moment où nous avons eu
ce débat sur les 25 meilleures années
se rapportant donc au régime de retraite
des non salariés agricoles
donc l'écriture telle qu'elle est faite
ne va plutôt bien en ce sens que la
revalorisation des pensions de retraite
bénéficiant du taux plein sera désormais
mieux assuré
mais dans le même temps la personne dont
je parle
et qui a bénéficié de cette retraite
particulière dans des conditions
particulières à 60 ans devrait
aujourd'hui
attendre les 62 ans
par conséquent nous demandons que soient
prises en considération ces situations
particulières
pour des catégories passer mal
expression qui ne roulent pas sur l'or
j'aimerais connaître donc quelle suite
vous envisagez de donner à ces
situations particulières de ces
personnes qui sont en situation de
nécessité pour le coup merci de votre
attention et le 4595
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues donc c'est
Joël Labbé mon collègue qui est à
l'initiative de cet amendement qu'il m'a
demandé de présenter parce qu'il espère
convaincre le gouvernement de le
rajouter à la liste des amendements
qu'il accepte et sinon ce but prévu par
l'article 42 9 de notre règlement
concernant l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution que je le présente
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé stagne
depuis 10 ans alors que la France occupe
l'une des meilleures places en matière
d'espérance de vie à la naissance elle
est assez proche de la moyenne
européenne pour l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé de plus cette espérance de
vie en bonne santé et marquée par de
fortes inégalités cela a été discuté et
reconnu lors des débats sur l'article 8
nous l'avons
dit sans relâche au cours des débats
cette réforme est injuste car ce sont
ces personnes dont l'espérance de vie a
fortiori l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et la plus faible qui subiront le
plus votre réforme à qui ce texte
viendra retirer les années de retraite
car rappelons-le l'espérance de vie à la
naissance des hommes et de 84,4 ans pour
les 5% les plus riches contre seulement
71,7 ans pour les 5 % les plus pauvres
soit un écart de 13 ans par cet
amendement nous souhaitons encore une
fois dénoncer le caractère injuste et
brutal de cette réforme et proposer
c'est ce que propose l'amendement que
les dimensions d'analyse de l'évolution
de l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
soit incluse dans le rapport annuel du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites avec
une attention particulière pour les
inégalités liées au genre et aux
catégories socio-professionnelles merci
chers collègues alors j'ai une dizaine
de sous amendements liés à ces deux
amendements le
5725 n'est pas défendu le 5729 madame
meunier
voilà un beau sujet dont nous aurions pu
débattre dans un cadre ordinaire dans un
sénat normal dans un cadre d'examen de
de loi classique mais telle n'est pas le
cas donc c'est un sous amendement que
nous proposons à l'amendement que vient
de présenter notre collègue qui complète
l'analyse en parlant d'espérance de vie
en bonne santé c'est un indicateur de
santé publique qui mesure le nombre
d'années que peut espérer vivre une
personne sans être limitée dans ses
activités quotidiennes par un problème
de santé l'espérance de vie à la
naissance s'allonge régulièrement mais
ces années supplémentaires de vie ne
sont cependant pas toutes nécessairement
en bonne santé en effet en 2021 les
hommes âgés de 65 ans peuvent espérer
vivre 11 ans et trois mois les femmes
âgées de 65 ans peuvent espérer vivre 12
ans et 6 mois derrière cette moyenne se
cache cependant d'énormes disparités si
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé a
augmenté dans tous les groupes sociaux
professionnels l'écart entre les
ouvriers et les cadres restent le même
une étude a montré que les ouvriers
vivent moins longtemps que les cadres et
qu'ils passent plus de temps que avec
des incapacités ou des handicaps une
analyse fine et précise de l'espérance
de vie sans incapacité de différentes
catégories socioprofessionnelles et donc
essentielles pour traiter les questions
de retraite avec plus de justice et plus
d'égalité
merci le 5738 monsieur ficher
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre est-il nécessaire
d'expliquer longuement que effectivement
les ouvriers les salariés qui sont
exposés de par leur métier à portée des
charges pénibles avant des travaux
exposés entre le shows et le froid et
entièrement des produits chimiques enfin
toutes ces choses qui font que les
risques de maladies la pénibilité
raccourcis l'espérance de vie c'est pour
ça que effectivement quand on dit la
moyenne de l'espérance de vie pour les
pour les hommes âgés de plus de 65 ans
et de 11,3 et pour les femmes de 12,6
ans on sait très bien que l'écart après
et beaucoup plus important que ça c'est
en cela d'ailleurs que les les ouvriers
les salariés quand la retraite a été
mise à 60 ans a l'air de François
Mitterrand en 1981 ou 82 il y a eu
vraiment une explosion de joie chez les
salariés et je peux porter témoignages
de gens que je connaissais qui portait
des caisses de vin depuis 30 ans des
caisses de bouteilles de douche là et
qui m'a dit son bonheur parce que en
partant à la retraite à 60 ans
effectivement il pouvait espérer est
encore en bonne santé et faire des
choses qui lui plaisaient pendant les 5
6 années ce qui s'est produit d'ailleurs
puisque après il a été obligé condamné à
rester au lit donc cet amendement là
propose de modifier
l'alinéa 3 de la 10 après avec les mots
chanter ajouter les mots et les
incidences sur la ville des activités
quotidiennes et après les mots aux gens
insérer les mots au niveau de vie ce qui
modifierait le texte je vous remercie
c'est le 5739 monsieur Ferro
merci merci monsieur le Président c'est
le même sous amendement mais quelques
minutes de plus pour évoquer un sujet
essentiel c'est à dire à la fois les
inégalités que va creuser cette réforme
des retraites et le fait que elle va
aller creuser sur un moment
crucial de la vie de la plupart des
hommes et des femmes c'est-à-dire les
premières années de la retraite qui sont
souvent parmi les plus belles années de
la vie celle aussi où on peut mener les
projets qu'il n'a pas été possible de
mener quand on travaillait or ce sens
bien ces deux années là que vous venez
prendre au français avec cette réforme
mais ces deux années là elles n'ont pas
la même valeur suivant que l'on soit
riche ou pauvre suivant la profession
que l'on exerce et souvent suivant
l'état de santé dans lequel on est à la
fin de sa période de travail et au début
de sa période de retraite alors ce
modeste amendement c'est sous amendement
ils sont là pour que demander que soit
établi de manière objective les
inégalités que creuse la réforme entre
les Français en fonction de leur
catégorie socioprofessionnelles et de
leur revenu parce que une réforme des
retraites qui ne luttent pas contre les
inégalités monsieur le ministre ce ne
sera jamais une réforme de gauche
merci le
5740 madame le héros
alors c'est un amendement un sous
amendement qui répond à la même
préoccupation que mes camarades
l'espérance de vie effectivement à la
naissance s'allonge régulièrement mais
ces années supplémentaires de vie ne
sont cependant pas toutes nécessairement
vécues en bonne santé je rappelle que
derrière cette moyenne se cache
d'énormes disparités si l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé a augmenté dans tous
les groupes sociaux professionnels
l'écart entre ouvrier et cadres restent
important et je crois qu'il est de 13
années d'écart alors je vais vous citer
l'exemple concret de cristal qui a 48
ans qui est aide-soignante qui est
diplômée depuis 1998 elle souffre de
douleurs cervicales et dorsales
d'arthrose d'arthrite les douleurs
étaient telles qu'elle a dû avoir
recours à un arrêt de travail de longue
durée à un traitement de base de
corticoïdes et un repose strict pour se
refaire un semblant de santé
elle doit tenir d'être postures pénible
la manutention des patients on sait est
très difficile les corps sont mis à rude
épreuve et il lui reste encore 15 ans à
travailler mais son corps n'en peut plus
alors
cette espérance de vie pour cette
personne en bonne santé je peux vous
dire elle a une réelle signification
donc nous demandons à ce que cette
élément particulier de d'espérance de
santé sur la vie et les activités
quotidiennes des personnes et au regard
de leur niveau de vie soit un élément
d'appréciation du rapport c'est le
5742 n'est pas défendu le 5743 madame la
Présidente rossignol
le rapport annuel du corps est un outil
précieux parce que c'est l'outil qui
nous permet de d'identifier
quels sont les réalités humaines
différentes qui sont qui se cachent
derrière des politiques sociales qui
sont le plus souvent uniforme on a beau
avoir discuté du temps on pouvait encore
discuter c'est à dire avant que le
gouvernement déclenche le 44-3 de et
discuter dans le but de d'avancer et de
faire adopter des amendements on a beau
avoir discuté de toutes les situations
spécifiques on a pour autant pas épuisé
à quel point cette réforme paraît
injuste pour tout le monde parce que
elle va en définitive appliquer le même
âge couper à tout le monde ça c'est dans
le rapport du corps déjà dans un nombre
de cas mais ce que nous voudrions avec
ces amendements c'est que les rapports
du corps soient encore plus fins mais
surtout qu'il servent à inspirer
réellement les choix politiques du
gouvernement c'est à dire que une fois
qu'on a constaté que les inégalités de
genre ou de sexe pardon des inégalités
de sexe ces inégalités sociales les
inégalités conditions les inégalités de
pouvoir d'achat impactent
considérablement la durée de vie
l'espérance de vie à la fois en bonne
santé et l'espérance de vie jusqu'au
décès le gouvernement entière des
politiques sociales qui soient justes
qui soient digne de ce qu'on vécu des
individus et dans cette affaire
aujourd'hui ce que le gouvernement nous
montre c'est que sa réforme elle fait fi
elle passe totalement elle engendre
totalement les réalités humaines qui
sont celles de tes vies des salariés
alors avec ces amendements là qui se
viennent se enrichir le très bon
amendement de notre collègue réponds ces
Monges c'est aussi Monsieur le Ministre
un appel à ce que vous changiez de
politique tout bonnement en fait faisons
les choses simplement nous essayons de
vous dire par tous nos amendements c'est
ce qui nous reste d'ailleurs tout ce
qu'on a plus que votre politique est une
politique injuste inégalitaire qui
aggravent les inégalités de sexe et qui
aggravent les inégalités sociales et que
nous souhaitons que vous engendiez merci
le
5744 sur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mais
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
avec la complicité de la droite dont on
ne distingue plus vraiment les
frontières avec votre famille politique
vous avez fait passer le report de l'âge
de la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
aujourd'hui c'est main dans la main que
vous vous accordez à bloquer le Sénat
mais surtout votre position
parmi vos arguments au cœur de parmi vos
arguments fallacieux au cœur de votre
argumentaire mensongé la question de
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie une
propagande efficace passe par de bons
éléments de langage et vous avez choisi
le vivre plus pour travailler plus a
priori logique efficace ce raisonnement
est simpliste réducteur et lacunaire
tout n'est pas si simple monsieur le
ministre vos tentatives pour tromper les
Français son veine en effet tout votre
argumentaire s'effondre quand on accorde
un minimum d'importance aux inégalités
qui touchent nos concitoyens et à
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé alors
oui l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
augmenté dans tous les groupes sociaux
professionnels cependant l'écart entre
ouvriers et cadre reste le même les
années ne valent pas le même prix selon
que l'on soit maçon et Bauer et gouttier
hôtesse de caisse à Jean d'entretien ou
banquier
d'affaires pour ne prendre que cet
exemple
avec cette réforme ce sont ceux qui
exercent des métiers pénibles que vous
pénalisez ce sont ceux qui se lèvent tôt
que vous punissez ce sont ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler jeune que vous les
ayez une analyse fine et précise de
l'espérance de vie sans incapacité des
différentes catégories
socio-professionnelles et donc
essentielles pour traiter la question
des retraites avec plus de justice et
d'égalité monsieur le ministre
peut-être ne vous rendez vous compte
avec cette analyse du caractère injuste
de votre réforme notre sous amendement
propose de la compléter par les
incidences de cette espérance de santé
sur la vie et les activités quotidiennes
des personnes qui regardent merci le
5745 Madame Van aigle
le 5746 monsieur Tissot
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le présent
sous amendement visant encadrer
précisément l'âge jusqu'auquel il est
possible d'obtenir le versement d'une
pension dite orphelin en écrivant
précisément dans la loi ce sous
amendement vise également à étendre ce
dispositif jusqu'à 25 ans tout d'abord
je tenais à saluer l'amendement des
rapporteurs qui indiquent qu'un niveau
de pension minimum doit être fixé et qui
inclut une majoration pour des orphelins
souffrant d'un handicap supérieur à 80%
avant 21 ans toutefois au sein de mon
groupe nous considérons que face aux
arbitrages budgétaires qui auront lieu
de lors de la CMP ou dans les nombreux
décrets prévus dans ce texte de loi il
est indispensable d'écrire précisément
dans la loi la borne d'âge pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce dispositif un coup de
rabais sur ce public là serait je pense
très difficilement acceptable et
certainement mal perçu pour une réforme
vous en conviendrez qui bénéficie pas
jusqu'ici d'un enthousiasme débordant en
toute logique nous vous proposons donc
l'âge de 25 ans afin de faire la
jonction avec le revenu de solidarité
active qui est accessible à partir de
ces messages là je pense notamment pour
ces personnes qui ont déjà vécu des
expériences difficiles il a du devoir de
la nation de les empêcher de tomber dans
la précarité qu'ils avaient 22 23 ou
même 25 ans et je pense que la
proposition que nous faisons suite la
logique que nous menons au sein du
groupe socialiste l'accès à l'ensemble
des droits sociaux dès que cela est
nécessaire et ses propositions nous
avons déjà apportées dans cette
hémicycle notamment avec la proposition
de loi de notre collègue Rémy Cardon que
je salue sur les droits nouveaux des 18
ans où nous portions l'ouverture du
bénéfice du RSA des 18 ans
Monsieur Tissot je suis pas sûr que ce
soit le bon amendement que vous avez non
non c'est pas sur le temps c'est que je
pense que là c'était sur le niveau de
vie la santé enfin bon allez ça changera
pas grand chose
5747 monsieur Cardon merci monsieur le
président
merci d'éviter de commenter les
amendements seul
puisque vous avez vous avez arrêté le
débat donc il faudrait pas commenter les
amendements quand même alors c'est sous
amendement permet d'ajouter des mots
importants notamment les incidents sur
la vie sur les activités quotidiennes
mais également sur le niveau de vie
chers collègues l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé est un indicateur de santé
publique qui mesure et vous le savez le
nombre d'années qui peut espérer vivre
une personne sans être limité dans ses
activités quotidiennes par un problème
de santé l'espérance de vie à la
naissance s'allonge régulièrement mais
ces années supplémentaires de vie ne
sont cependant pas nécessaire elles sont
pas forcément vides en bonne santé alors
en 2021 les hommes âgés de 65 ans
peuvent espérer vivre 11 ans de plus
les femmes âgées de 65 ans peuvent
espérer vivre 12 ans de plus alors
effectivement derrière cette moyenne se
cache cependant d'énormes disparités si
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé a
augmenté dans tous les groupes
socioprofessionnels l'écart entre un
ouvrier et un cadre reste le même je
pense qu'on vous a suffisamment rappelé
cela une étude a montré que les ouvriers
vivent moins longtemps que les cadres et
qui passent plus de temps que avec une
incapacité et un handicap après des
années de labeur
une analyse fine et précise de
l'espérance de vie notamment sur son
incapacité des différences catégories
socioprofédales et donc essentiel à
traiter sur la question des retraites
avec plus de justice et d'égalité notre
sous-amendement propose de compléter
l'analyse prévue par l'amendement numéro
45 95 de notre collègue et d'ajouter
l'incidence de cette espérance de santé
sur la vie et les activités quotidiennes
des personnes au regard de leur niveau
de vie je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Cardon la parole est au rapporteur sur
l'ensemble des amendements et sous
amendements merci je voudrais rassurer
mes collègues que le temps le corps que
le comité de suivi des retraites n'a pas
attendu tous ces amendements pour se
pencher sur la problématique des
espérances de vie par rapport au niveau
de vie il y a des travaux permanents
mais relisez les relisez les débats il y
a des travaux permanents depuis des
relustres là dessus mais sont des sujets
d'importance ce sont des sujets
d'importance qui méritent une attention
particulière donc je donnerai un avis
défavorable par rapport à tous ces
amendements répétitifs mais il m'importe
de répondre à monsieur laelec a soulevé
un vrai problème un vrai problème parce
qu'il a il a bien exposé les difficultés
notamment du monde agricole et qui fait
que il faut être attentif pour qu'il
puisse bénéficier de ce niveau pour ceux
qui peuvent atteindre carrière complète
cotisés entièrement cotisée au SMIC pour
pouvoir bénéficier quand ils ont l'âge
et l'ensemble de la durée d'un taux
plein que les choses soient claires 85 %
du SMIC net
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons veillé à ce que la PMR puisse être
valorisée d'une part et que nous avons
été attentifs par rapport à la durée
parce qu'il y avait un problème au
niveau du complément différentiel qu'il
fallait qu'il reste suffisamment on a
essayé de régler ça je suis pas sûr
qu'on arrive à tout et nombre
d'agriculteurs auront encore une
allocation de ressources que l'on
appelle la SPA effectivement auquel ils
font pas suffisamment appel du fait de
du recours sur le succession mais voilà
un peu la réponse que je souhaitais
fournir à cette question précise merci
de l'avoir posé le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est
défavorable sur les sous-amendements et
l'amendement et je complète la réponse
de monsieur le rapporteur en disant que
le fait de considérer comme complète les
carrières interrompus pour une question
d'invalidité va permettre à 45000
retraités qui étaient des exploitants
agricoles de bénéficier la garantie
Chassaigne pour un montant moyen de 80
euros par mois alors qu'il n'en
bénéficient pas aujourd'hui merci le
oui je vous en prie pardon oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues donc je me
permets au nom de ma collègue Mélanie
Vogel c'est la crise des Françaises et
Français établir de France de vous
rappeler une absence remarquable de ce
texte les Françaises et Français ayant
une carrière internationale or leur
situation est particulière et bien trop
souvent de trop nombreuses dispositions
de notre système de retraite les les
pénalises un exemple le fameux minimum
contributif majoré le myco majoré le
myco majoré qui vise à garantir une
pension à celles et ceux qui ont cotisé
à de faibles salaires il est
actuellement de
747,57 euros brut pour avoir droit au
myco majoré il faut avoir cotisé au
moins 120 trimestres la réforme comme
nous savons vise à augmenter le myco
majoré bien sauf que cette augmentation
ne bénéficiera pas française et français
étrangers bien souvent ils et elles
n'ont pas cotisé son intimes soit 30 ans
en France et sont donc inéligibles aux
mycos je pourrais évoquer d'autres
exemples mais ce n'est pas mon point le
point est que malheureusement les
Françaises et Français avec des
carrières internationales sont
systématiquement oubliés ce projet de
loi en est malheureusement la preuve
qu'il faut donc changer de méthode il
faut que les impacts négatifs sur les
Français des Français de l'étranger ces
ruptures d'égalité soient
systématiquement recensés ce qui est
indispensable pour y remédier donc
Mélanie Vogel en tant que sénatrice des
Françaises et Français de l'étranger est
en échange régulier avec nos
compatriotes établiors de France qui se
préoccupent de l'avenir de leur retraite
certains et certaines et certains sont
même devenus de véritables experts
défendant leur cause y compris devant
l'Assemblée des Français d'étrangers
mais cette situation ne peut plus durer
car il manque cruellement un recensement
de ces impacts négatifs de ces ruptures
d'égalité c'est la raison pour laquelle
son amendement vise à ce que le comité
de suivi des retraites inclut dans son
rapport annuel une section analysant les
conséquences sur les retraites des
Françaises et Français de l'étranger
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur t'es un vrai sujet là aussi
qui doit être traité au niveau du corps
CSR donc satisfaisant pour l'instant
malgré la complexité du dispositif
exposé
c'est le ministre
merci trois amendements identiques le
2059 qui le défend madame Estrosi
Sassone
si monsieur le Président cet amendement
est proposé par le président Bruno
Retailleau et par l'ensemble des membres
de notre groupe il s'agit d'un
amendement de justice et qui vise à
corriger une inégalité de traitement les
enfants devenus orphelins dont les
parents étaient affiliés au régime
général ne peuvent pas bénéficier d'une
pension au titre de ce régime or si
leurs parents étaient affiliés au régime
de la fonction publique ces enfants
devenus orphelins pourraient en
bénéficier dans cet amendement nous
proposons donc que les enfants dont les
parents étaient affiliés au régime
général puissent bénéficier d'une
pension d'orphelins jusqu'à leur 21 ans
et par ailleurs pour tenir compte de la
situation de handicap des orphelins
souffrant d'un handicap supérieur à 80%,
le bénéfice de la pension de réversion
nous souhaitons qui leur soit attribué
quel que soit leur âge
merci amendement identique du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre le
2569 merci monsieur le Président il est
défendu il a essentiellement vocation à
lever toute forme dire responsabilité
l'article 40 merci
allez madame Doineau monsieur Savary lui
identique le 4736
je demande pas à la Commission sur la
vie par définition c'est le même au
gouvernement son avis c'est le même
merci
le 4650 monsieur le ministre
pardon monsieur le Président c'est
effectivement une demande de
coordination faire en sorte d'assimiler
les périodes de congés de présence
parentale et de congé de projets dons au
trimestre cotisé pour le droit aux myco
ou au micro garantie et la commission
favorable merci le 2155 de la Commission
merci avis du gouvernement favorable
non
on peut pas s'exprimer non on peut pas
s'exprimer
2058 madame Estrosi Sassone
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
donc toujours de l'amendement proposé
par le président Retailleau et par
l'ensemble des membres de notre groupe
la location de solidarité aux personnes
âgées ou ce que l'on appelle le minimum
vieillesse et verser au retraité
justifiant de faibles ressources et
résidant sur le territoire français la
prestation n'est pas exportable l'assuré
doit en effet justifier qu'il réside 6
mois en France au cours de l'année
civile pour bénéficier de cette
prestation dans l'amendement que nous
vous proposons nous souhaitons que cette
condition de résidence soit portée à 9
mois pour les allocations prenant effet
à compter du 1er septembre 2023 et cela
en cohérence avec les règles applicables
pour le bénéfice du Revenu de Solidarité
Active
ah oui la commission favorable à
gouvernement merci
24 amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le
3951 qui le défend monsieur Bocquet
monsieur le Président cet amendement
vise à des conditionner la location de
solidarité aux personnes âgées à son
remboursement par les héritiers en effet
et malgré les dépensions de retraite
bien plus petites qu'en métropole dues
aux carrières incomplètes à une activité
plus faible des salaires de référence
bas certains et certaines de nos
compatriotes font le choix de refuser de
recourir à la SPA
il y a elles le font à cause des
conditions de remboursement lors de la
succession et craignent de mettre en
danger l'héritage dessiner leurs enfants
ce besoin de léguer un bien de faire
montre de générosité supplantent le
souci de vivre décemment leur retraite
sans expliquer la totalité du nom
recours qui s'élevait en 2016 à 50%,
notons tout de même qu'il est de 43%
pour les montants attendus les plus
élevés c'est-à-dire plus de 700 euros le
montant économisé entre guillemets par
le non-recourt s'élève d'après l'adresse
et toujours en 2016 à 1,1 milliard
d'euros le taux de nos recours des
femmes et de 8 points plus élevés que
celui des hommes il atteint même 62%
quand les locataires éligible touche une
pension de réversion nous refusons de
placer les femmes et les hommes vivant
déjà de peu face à ces quatre
consciences une allocation de solidarité
se doit de l'être réellement de même il
ne peut revenir aux enfants de
rembourser la location de leurs parents
qui avaient de très très faible revenu
considéré que la SPA aucune avance
consentie par la société aménage pauvre
que les héritiers je mets des guillemets
devront rembourser revient à nous placer
résolument du côté du maintien des
déterminés déterminismes sociaux merci
merci chers collègues le 778 monsieur
Cabanel merci monsieur le Président
c'est un amendement porté par notre
collègue Maryse carrer une étude de
l'adresse de l'année dernière estimée en
effet que le non recours au minimum
vieillesse concerné près de 50% parmi
des personnes seules selon recours
s'expliquerait en grande partie par le
fait que les bénéficiaires potentiels ne
demandent pas l'aide par peur d'imputer
leur héritage l'article 10 vise
notamment à lutter contre le non recours
à la location de solidarité aux
personnes âgées le seuil de récupération
sur succession de cette allocation
devrait ainsi être portée de 39 à
100.000 euros dès le 1er septembre 2023
et indexé sur l'inflation de façon
pérenne c'est une bonne chose puisque ce
seuil n'a jamais été revalorisé depuis
pour autant comme le rappellent le
rapport des formations de la famille
nationale de 2016 sur l'évaluation des
politiques publiques en faveur de
l'accès au droit sociaux le non recours
au droit des prestations loin d'être une
économie pour la nation mine notre pacte
social pour cette raison notre
amendement propose de supprimer la
récupération de succession de la SPA qui
pénalise l'accès à cette allocation
notamment dans les départements ruraux
merci le 3689 monsieur plat
merci monsieur le Président c'est une
amendement porté avec mon collègue
sénateur du Gard Denis boide alors nous
discutons de la réforme des retraites la
question du niveau de vie des retraités
français méritaient d'être posés en
France métropolitaine un million de
Français âgés de plus de 65 ans vivent
aujourd'hui sous le seuil de pauvreté au
moment où je vous parle j'ai une pensée
émue pour mes deux grands-mères qui
comme des milliers de femmes après
s'être usée toute leur vie à la tâche
que ce soit la vigne au champ et en même
temps au tâches domestiques se
retrouvent à 90 ans avec une pension de
retraite indé
nous sachant que ce choix il n'est pas
un calcul rationnel il repose uniquement
sur une volonté de transmission du
patrimoine cherna acquis à leurs enfants
donc revenons sur l'espace supplément la
possibilité de reprise de la SPA
malheureusement c'est
cette pantalonade parmentaire nous
permettra pas de nous prononcer sur
cette mesure d'aide retraité pauvre
alors je vous invite monsieur le
ministre avec force et je vous regarde
dans les yeux de mettre en place cette
dispositif ne le faites pas pour moi
mais au moins faites-le pour l'ensemble
de ces retraités pauvres merci
le
3324 madame poncemonge oui merci
monsieur le Président alors
effectivement de raison pour cela
c'est scandaleux parce que parce que ça
produit du non recours ça vient d'être
dit et puis de cette scandaleux parce
que c'est une taxation sur succession
réservée au plus modestes alors que
fleurissent les contournements de la
taxation des gros patrimoines
je voudrais aussi dire que sur 17
millions de retraités
5,8 millions de retraités touchent moins
de 1000 euros
alors ils ont cru effectivement la
revalorisation mais il fallait la
condition de carrière complète et là 4
millions ne sont plus concernés 4
millions ont été éliminés reste 1,8
millions ah oui carrière complète mais
pas forcément à plein temps d'où
provatisation d'où 30% qui auront moins
de 30 euros pour une pour une promesse
qui est faite depuis 2008 et qui n'est
pas impliqué depuis 2017 monsieur le
ministre dit la moitié soit 900000
toucheront plus de 70 euros certes mais
on veut savoir combien à 100 euros la
réponse monsieur le rapporteur nous l'a
donné 125 000 doux sur 5 millions 8 de
retraités 125
000 personnes sur 5,8 millions qui
seront les 100 millions et 4 millions de
personnes de la toucheront pas 100 euros
ah oui 100 millions ça c'est pour les
gros patrimoine bien c'est une histoire
un peu comme les 10 petits je
sais qu'on dit plus ce titre d'Agatha
Christie mais vous voyez on est parti de
5,8 millions on a plus de 125000 qui ont
100 euros et la moitié est 4 millions
qui ont cru à cela parce que vous avez
parlé de taux plein mais pour les gens
tout plein il savent pas ce que c'est
ils savent pas que vous parliez de la
carrière complète et les 4 millions
comptés exclus ce sont les femmes qui
n'avaient pas la carrière complète on
sait qu'elles sont là les femmes c'est
le
4597 monsieur Boyer
merci monsieur le Président je défends
cet amendement que souhaitait défendre
mon collègue joël Labbé même si nos
débats n'ont plus qu'une utilité
relative compte tenu de la mise en
oeuvre du 44 alinéa 3 qui fait que nous
débattons plutôt nous ne débattons pas
nous présentons nos amendements donc
l'objet de cet amendement c'est d'abord
un amendement de repli qu'avec ses
collègues du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire Joël souhaite
proposer augmenter le seuil de
recouvrement sur succession de
l'allocation de solidarité pour les
personnes âgées un montant minimal de
300.000 euros pour rappel l'adversaire
peut en effet être repris sur la
succession du bénéficiaire après son
décès sur la fraction de l'actif net qui
excède 39000 euros un montant porté à
100 000 euros pour les outre-mer le
gouvernement s'est engagé par ce projet
de loi apporté par décret ce montant à
100.000 euros si le groupe écologiste
solid jamais été territoires souhaitent
la suppression de la règle de
récupération sur succession de l'ASPA il
propose par cet amendement de repli de
fixer dans la loi un rehaussement du
seuil de recouvrement pour la métropole
et les outre-mer à un niveau de 300000
euros correspondant à des patrimoines de
gens modeste la récupération sur
succession de la SPA en effet
scandaleuse car elle est bien une
taxation sur succession qui est réservée
au plus modeste d'entre nous alors que
fleurissent de nombreux contournements
dès lors qu'il s'agit de gros patrimoine
il a été montré ça a été évoqué par les
collègues avant moi que cette
récupération était une raison importante
dans tous les milieux populaires pour ne
pas avoir recours à la SPA vous savez
très bien que dans les milieux
populaires lorsqu'on a réussi à mettre
un bien de côté et bien on fait tout
pour le préserver et le transmettre à
ses enfants parce qu'on sait que la vie
sans aucun bien est dure merci de
prendre en compte le débat sur cet
article qui hélas ne sera peut-être pas
repris par le ministre merci le 4598 qui
le défend oui je vous en prie Monsieur
salmon
merci monsieur le Président
un amendement également de notre
collègue joël Labbé c'est un amendement
de repli visa augmenter le seuil de
recouvrement de l'ASPA à 200 000 euros à
l'occasion de la défense de cet
amendement nous voir roulons rappeler
que si le gouvernement voulait
véritablement agir sur le non recours à
la SPA il aurait pu évaluer et mettre en
œuvre une automatisation de son
versement accouplé bien sûr avec une
suppression de la récupération sur la
succession rappelons les chiffres selon
l'adresse en 2016 sur 646
000 personnes éligibles seulement 50%
d'entre elles percevaient effectivement
ce minimum vieillesse l'autre moitié
n'ayant pas fait la demande
si la récupération sur la succession est
un facteur de non recours les chiffres
sur les autres difficultés d'accès sont
très claires si cette allocation est
connue de 62% des Français seuls 19%
d'entre eux savent assez précisément qui
peut en bénéficier dans un rapport
d'octobre 2021 la Cour des comptes
soulignait le taux élevé de nos recours
en pointant la complexité du dispositif
elle soulignait également les résultats
d'une enquête de 2018 réalisée par la
CCMSA auprès de plusieurs caisses de son
réseau
ces résultats ont confirmé la nécessité
d'une information sur le minimum
vieillesse plus systématique auprès des
personnes éligibles afin de diminuer le
taux de non recours
ceci pose une fois de plus la question
des inégalités face aux services publics
et au système d'aide de l'État les
inégalités se cumulent et créent un
système qui rend plus difficile la
sortie de la précarité une personne en
situation de précarité aura bien moins
de ressources pour accéder à la
connaissance des aides sociales et pour
en effectuer la demande pendant ce temps
vous le savez aménage aisé pourra quant
à lui déployer des moyens pour obtenir
l'aide de conseiller en gestion de
patrimoine pour bénéficier des nombreux
dispositifs d'optimisation fiscale qui
existe dans notre pays merci le 159
monsieur Lurel ah pardon
je rappelle quand même quelques faits en
on demande la suppression de ce seuil de
récupération sur succession on a eu les
pires difficultés avec Bercy finalement
on a trouvé un compromis de dire que
compte tenu de l'état des patrimoine et
du niveau des prix là-bas on le porte à
100000 euros et s'il restait à 39000
euros on demandait simplement de revenir
à la pratique de Lionel Jospin où il y
avait pas de récupération et ce sont les
gouvernements du président sarouzi qui
sont revenus à un texte un seuil de 1982
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que moi je
demanderai la suppression de cette
affaire parce qu'il s'agit là d'une
injustice je demande donc puisque on
peut pas débattre et bien que
contrairement à ce que demande le
gouvernement qui demande de lui confier
la chose par décret comme si c'est une
sorte d'ordonnance qu'on demandait en
faisant confiance aveuglement
gouvernement non c'est dans le texte
c'est la loi qui l'a fait on demande
simplement que on supprime le mot
outremer collectivités
de l'article 73 et 74 de la
reconstitution et que ce soit étendu à
toute la nation voilà
c'est monsieur Lurel le 2912 cette
fois-ci c'est Monsieur Stanzione
président monsieur le ministre ben vous
venez d'être interpellé sur cette
question et encore une fois on peut
déplorer que nous ne puissions pas
débattre de cette question puisque vous
voyez le nombre d'interventions qui ont
lieu à propos de la SPA cette allocation
de solidarité aux personnes âgées elle
est portée à
961,08 par personne seule ou 1492 euros
pour un couple et c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui vient au secours des plus
démunis et comme le évoqué
certaines de mes collègues précédemment
à peine 50% de bénéficiaires
qui pourraient le percevoir en ont fait
la demande et déjà il faudrait que ce
soit automatisé alors que se passait-il
au moment du décès du retraité qui est
bénéficiaire
et bien monsieur le ministre
il faudrait que par décret vous puissiez
graver dans le marbre un engagement du
gouvernement
qui avait promis de porter la somme à
100000 euros au lieu des 39000 euros
alors vous avez le choix monsieur le
ministre puisque plusieurs possibilités
ont été apportées par mes collègues pour
faire le bon choix et en définitive il
est possible que la proposition
de du sénateur Lurel soit la meilleure
c'est à dire qu'il y ait une exonération
complète du droit merci chers collègues
le 256 de la Commission
oui merci la Commission a souhaité
inscrire directement dans la loi la
somme de 100000 euros correspondant
justement au recours de succession de
façon à ce que ça revalorisation se
fasse à partir d'un seuil bien défini
merci
identique le 2499 monsieur Lurel merci
monsieur le Président là j'avoue être un
peu étonné
le rapporteur vient de dire bon c'est
simple on va généraliser je la remercie
mais il donne un avis défavorable sur un
amendement identique la Commission a
émis alors à strictement
identique il n'a pas lu l'amendement ou
alors problème de paternité on veut se
réserver tout ça un sentiment de
propriété monsieur le rapporteur je vous
demande de donner un avis favorable pour
cet amendement est-ce qu'on est bien
d'accord
vous allez le retirer ou alors vous
allez voilà c'est défendu merci le
2574 qui le défend alors
c'est le même
il défendu c'est le même très bien merci
le
3968 je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues cette amendement de repli en
temps relever le seuil au-delà duquel le
remboursement de l'ASPA est dû par les
héritiers nous proposons de le rehausser
à 300000 euros afin que les personnes
âgées éligibles ne s'en prive pas pour
favoriser l'héritage laissé à leur
enfant il faut aller voir cher collègue
les pages et les pages de forum de
personnes qui découvrent l'espace sur
les conseils de leur caisse de retraite
étant de léguer leur maison
principalement à leurs enfants on se
pose la question de la donation en
nu-propriété et puis on apprend que les
donations de moins de 10 ans sont
réintégrées dans la succession que
l'héritier doit rembourser découpe se
demandent si le survivant devra vendre
la maison pour rembourser l'ASPA de son
conjoint d'autres mettent de côté le peu
qu'ils ont pour rembourser eux-mêmes
leur ASPA je pense que vous avez compris
à quel point cela est sinistre
merci le 157 monsieur Lurel à nouveau
le Président c'est toujours dans la même
veine
de
supprimer l'alinéa 13
qui
empêche de supprimer ce que la loi
égalité réelle avait porté comme progrès
je rappelle que sur le fond
c'est
identique madame Concorde le 610 il est
défendu monsieur le président
également
le 3953 qui le défend monsieur le
Président Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai pas
voulu faire un rappel au règlement tout
à l'heure il faudra quand même vous
expliquer comment l'abandon du président
rotaïo 2059 a été rejeté par le ministre
au titre de l'article 40 sans avoir été
déclaré il receva précédemment petit
mystère mais bon peut-être qu'on nous
expliquera un jour pourquoi
janvier à mon amendement qui vise à
supprimer le seuil au-delà duquel le
remboursement de la SPA est dû par les
héritiers la SPA correspond au minimum
accordé à toute personne n'ayant pas de
pension atteignant 961 euros aussi il
est possible de compléter chacun sa ici
jusqu'à ce montant une mention plus une
pension plus faible or elle fait partie
de prestations sociales récupérables
après le décès de la locataire si les
actifs de celui-ci ou de celle-ci sont
inférieure à 100000 euros soit déjà en
vigueur dans les outre-mer nous n'avons
plus nous exprimer précédemment sur la
vision qu'entraîne cette avance sur
héritage en quelque sorte et ses effets
produits une vieillesse dans des
conditions misérables pour les
allocataires souhaitant transmettre un
héritage à leurs enfants et qui donc
hésite à bénéficier de cette allocation
nous sommes pour notre part attaché
à ce que les personnes allocataires
bénéficient cette allocation solidarité
si elle remplit évidemment les
conditions d'éligibilité
faute de mieux nous sommes favorables à
réhausser le seuil applicable si les
bénéficiaires de la SPA de la SPA oui
savent qu'elle ne elle peut être repris
sur la succession
il est elles sont rarement fait du
dispositif il y a beaucoup
d'éloignements ils ne sont pas forcément
courants et tout ça conduit à une
mésestime de la réalité que personne ne
vient contredire et qui plutôt que de
recouvrer des allocations de survie
devrait constituer une politique
publique volontaire aussi nous proposons
de supprimer le seuil afin de balayer
l'écran des personnes éligibles et
d'augmenter le recours à cette
allocation que toute personne agit sans
ressource mérite merci monsieur le
Président le 2230 monsieur Lurel
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
de l'actif successoral la résidence
principale du bénéficiaire de la SPA
alors ça se fait déjà pour l'agriculture
il serait difficile de démanteler une
exploitation agricole ne serait-ce que
pour satisfaire à l'égalité des lots
la contenu du prix du foncier du prix du
mètre carré qui a la Réunion ou dans les
Caraïbes et partout compte tenu de la
dimension de ces territoires des îles où
le foncier est très cher ça monte très
vite et donc la plupart des gens ont
souvent construit comme on dit en coup
de mai
il se trouve propriétaire de leur maison
beaucoup et j'ai passé mon temps moi un
peu plus jeune à faire la retraite des
gens leur faire la liquidation les gens
refusaient de signer d'avoir recours à
la SPA parce qu'elles avaient les
personnes avaient peur d'avoir recours à
ça en disant je veux laisser quelque
chose à mes enfants il serait je crois
de bonne politique d'exclure
la résidence principale ou peut-être il
y a émettre un coefficient quelconque
pour diminuer
le montant qui serait dans le périmètre
de l'actif successoire tel est le sens
de l'amende merci chers collègues le
2579 qui le présente
défendu allez défendu le 614 madame
Concorde oui monsieur le Président ça
vient complément de ce que vient de dire
Victoria Lurel vous savez dans la
récupération de latifa il faudrait
vraiment sortir la résidence principale
comme il a expliqué habite sympa
particulier souvent fait de ce qu'on
appelle des coups de main c'est-à-dire
les gens qui aident les autres à
construire leur maison et si cette
maison même si elle vaut 100000 euros
devrait être saisi c'est vraiment
déposséder des gens qui ont dû avoir
recours à cette à cette allocation
supplémentaire pour toutes les raisons
que j'ai énuméré tout à l'heure merci et
le 2500 monsieur Lurel
merci
j'ai quelques réminiscences de mon latin
de cuisine
mais oui
on parle davantage différentiel dans cet
abonnement alors j'apprenais quand
c'était iris paribus si
toute chose également par ailleurs si on
devait garder les quarts 39000
aujourd'hui tout le monde serait à
100000 si on regarde cette écart et bien
il faudrait le porter au niveau évoqué
par certains de nos collègues 300.000
250000 alors on sait plus à faire ce
calcul de dire bien dans les outre-mer
pour garder l'écart qui était 2,5 fois
plus élevé que le niveau national le
niveau hexagonald pardon et bien il
faudrait le porter là à 250
000 euros je suis sûr c'est de nature à
convaincre notre ministre
on verra le 106 madame Mallet oui
monsieur le Président merci c'est
amendement vise à relever aussi le seuil
de récupération de la SPA dans les
collectivités régies par l'article 73 de
la Constitution en effet si la loi du 28
février 2017 relative à l'égalité réelle
dans les autres mères apporter le seuil
du relèvement du seuil de récupération
sur section de 39000 à 100.000 euros
dans les collectivités régies par
l'article 73 de la Constitution jusqu'au
1er janvier 2017 cela n'a néanmoins pas
réduit le non recours à la location de
solidarité aux personnes âgées dans les
outre-mer en effet dans beaucoup de
familles modestes la personne âgée
contribue au fonctionnement familial par
l'apport de la propriété du logement et
ce capital immobilier représente souvent
la seule richesse économique partagée
par la famille
le principe de récupération de l'espace
sur l'actif net au moment de la
succession constitue pour ces ménages un
frein insupportable nos seniors
préfèrent bien souvent vivre sous le
seuil de pauvreté plutôt que de gager
leur seul bien ainsi c'est un amendement
propose de porter
à 100 000 à 150 000 ce seuil je vous
remercie merci chers collègues le 612
madame Concorde
oui monsieur le Président on est sur le
même sujet et là n'oublions pas que ce
seuil à Spa qui est prévu pour être
pérennisé jusqu'en 2026 2026 c'est tout
près c'est après-demain donc il faut
penser dès maintenant à pérenniser ce
seuil et qu'on ne revienne pas au seuil
ridicule de 30 et quelques mille euros
qu'on connaissait avant je vous vois
prouver monsieur le Président je vous
remercie
le 158 monsieur Lurel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue
c'est pour objet
de prolonger le dispositif jusqu'en 2036
mais
si j'ai bien suivi le rapporteur peut me
répondre que c'est déjà satisfait je
veux comprendre que dans l'amendement
adopté par la commission et celle que
j'ai eu l'honneur avec d'autres de
portée que il n'y a plus de date et
c'est plus une expérimentation et que
elle est périmée bon si c'est ça je suis
prêt à me ranger à votre avis qui sera
bien entendu
presque favorable puisque vous me direz
qu'il est satisfait
merci enfin dans l'allias le 3955
monsieur salvadelli oui merci monsieur
le Président celui-ci
cet amendement visa exclure la résidence
principale du champ de recouvrement de
la location de solidarité de la personne
âgée j'irai dire à l'image des
agriculteurs pour lesquels le capital
d'exploitation n'est pas pris en compte
nous connaissons ici dans l'hémicycle
tout ce phénomène quand la spéculation
immobilière fait rage et que les prix au
mètre carré s'envolent sur des
territoires où les revenus des habitants
et des habitants de son faible ça pose
d'énormes problèmes de succession
je pourrais évoquer mais ça a été fait
par d'autres bien mieux par mois mais
alors là quand on parle des Outre-mer ça
prend un visage dont nous parlons
d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs amendements
déjà du non recours à la location de
solidarité par solidarité
intergénérationnelle avec leurs
descendants et nous n'avons plus notre
groupe regardez un document du corps
daté de janvier 192 2014 qui compare le
chiffre des allocataires propriétaires
et ceux qui ne sont pas constatent que
les propriétaires ne recourt pas à la
SPA malgré un taux de pauvreté important
je vous cite le document de travail
qu'il existerait un effet d'éviction les
propriétaires recouraient peu au minimum
vieillesse contrairement aux noms
propriétaires qui de ce fait
représenterait l'essentiel des effectifs
bénéficiaires pour vous donner l'échelle
des montants de plus les montants
récupérés en 2010 sont particulièrement
faibles c'est 130 millions pour 2
milliards d'euros d'allocations versées
c'est quand même un sacré
donc nous n'avons pas mes chers
collègues à faire face à une action de
délinquance visant détourner le minimum
vieillesse et je vous dis ça vous savez
mon opinion essaie de notre groupe nous
énonçons projet de loi après projet de
loi les abaissements d'états les cadeaux
fiscaux qui coûtent des millions et des
milliards aux Français aux Françaises et
on peut pas laisser la fierté à des
personnes sans ressources de léguer une
maison familiales donc le principe même
d'une récupération sur un minimum
vieillesse auquel nous contribuons tous
et toutes nous posent problème le fond
de solidarité vieillesse est alimenté en
majorité de CSG par la solidarité
nationale et de ne devrait pas dans ce
cas il ponctionner aussi d'une forme de
solidarité familiale je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur sur ces 24
amendements merci effectivement on va
pas parler des seuils de succession
différents selon les autres simplement
nous avons souhaité inscrire à 100.000
euros dans la loi donc à vif favorable
des amendements équivalents à celui que
j'ai proposé c'est à dire de 2156 donc
effectivement
2564 et 2499 qui sont identiques mille
excuses nous avons fait une erreur sur
4800 amendements on a le droit un petit
peu à l'erreur me semble-t-il une
mention tout à fait particulière donc
avis des favorable pour les autres une
mention particulière pour les autres
mères on a été sensible au démarche
Viviane Valley
Mallet pardon a proposé effectivement un
seuil qui paraît plus raisonnable qui
mérite que on puisse le négocier avec le
gouvernement il faut que véritablement
monsieur le ministre vous nous écoutiez
dans ce domaine là je crois qu'il y a
une vraie différence qui a été largement
exprimée et nous souhaiterions bien que
cette disposition soit reprise au niveau
notamment de la CMP c'est la raison pour
laquelle la Commission avait donné un
avis défavorable au départ parce que le
montant est à 250000 euros mais comme
elle a abaissé à un seuil resome là elle
150.000 euros je me permettrai à titre
personnel de donner un avis favorable
sur l'amendement de Viviane Mallet
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président pour revenir
peut-être sur la création et l'idée même
de l'aspal la location de solidarité des
personnes âgées c'est une allocation qui
a été pensée pour compléter la retraite
de ce que une toute petite pension la
portée à un niveau qui reste modeste
niveau que nous avons revalorisé de 100
euros il y a 3 ans et qui s'élève
aujourd'hui autour de 960 euros et cette
allocation a été pensée pour se
substituer finalement à la solidarité
familiale lorsque celle-ci n'existe pas
ou lorsque celle-ci n'est pas exercée et
si initialement l'ASPA a été pensé avec
une reprise sur succession c'est parce
que le législateur qui va créer a
considérer que à défaut de solidarité
familiale il était logique qu'en cas de
présence d'un patrimoine à l'époque
considéré comme conséquent il est
reprise au titre de la succession ce
niveau de patrimoine n'a jamais été
revalorisé depuis 82 et donc ça fait
plus de 40 ans que nous avons un niveau
de patrimoine pour déterminer la reprise
qui est fixée à 39 39000 euros ce qui
est évidemment un effet très
désincitatif ce qui explique aussi le
faible niveau de recours le gouvernement
s'est engagé à ce que ce niveau de
patrimoine à partir duquel il a repris
sur succession soit porté à 100.000
euros nous avions pris cet engagement et
prévu de le faire par décret comme
c'était le cas monsieur le rapporteur et
les amendements présentés par Monsieur
lurèle Madame jaspin et défendu par
Madame Concorde propose de l'inscrire
dans la loi soit c'est un avis favorable
pour cette raison là et il y a une
deuxième raison à cet avis favorable
c'est que l'amendement proposé notamment
par monsieur le rapporteur mais cela a
été repris par les deux amendements
identiques proposent que ce seuil de
100000 euros soit indexé sur l'inflation
ce qui fait que nos successeurs ne se
trouveront pas dans la situation que
nous connaissons c'est à dire l'absence
de revalorisation pendant des décennies
et des décennies voilà pourquoi la vie
est favorable sur le 2056 identique
défavorable sur tous les autres je dis
comme monsieur le rapporteur que le
différentiel de seuil de reprise de
succession entre la France
métropolitaine et la France des
Outre-mer
vous expliquer par un certain d'éléments
dans certains territoires relatifs au
prix du foncier c'est très hétérogène
des amendements avaient été proposés
cela te dit à 250 000 euros parfois même
un peu plus ça ne nous paraissait pas
raisonnable dans le cadre de la
préparation de la CNP il faut qu'on
puisse le regarder je tiens simplement à
préciser de manière générale pas
seulement pour les autres mères que
100000 euros c'est le patrimoine médian
et donc il faut aussi l'avoir en tête
dès lors qu'on dépasse 100000 euros on
dépasse le patrimoine médian ce qui
signifie malgré tout que le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'espace qui veut dire
caractérisé par des tout petits revenus
mais qui ont un patrimoine par
bénéficiaire supérieur à 100.000 euros
et malgré tout relativement réduit dès
lors que c'est le patrimoine médian donc
favorable au 2056 et aux deux identiques
et défavorables à tous les autres
merci monsieur le ministre je passe aux
4700 monsieur ferdin oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues alors que ce projet de loi
propose d'augmenter le Myco ainsi que le
micro majoré le gouvernement semble
avoir oublié que les personnes qui ont
travaillé une partie de leur vie
professionnelle à l'étranger ne sont
généralement pas éligibles
les personnes qui ont cotisé 120
trimestres en France ce qui n'est pas le
cas pour la majorité des Françaises et
Français de l'étranger comme je viens de
l'évoquer lors de la défense de
l'amendement précédent de Mélanie vosgel
d'autre part le versement du micro est
conditionné à une autre condition c'est
le cas de le dire le micro étant une
pension qui vise à garantir un certain
niveau de retraite à celles et ceux qui
ont eu toute leur vie à salaire faible
il est versé au sol retraité dont le
montant total des pensions et retraites
ne dépassent pas
1322,87 mensuellement ce plafond tient
également compte d'une éventuelle
pension par un pays tiers même si le
plafonnement est évidemment tout à fait
justifié vu la nature du dispositif il
pénalise en état les assurés avec une
carrière internationale qui ont peu
cotisé en France et ont de ce fait une
faible retraite française n'ayant pas le
droit aux myco le montant de leur
retraite est moins élevé que celui d'une
personne qui n'est pas partie à
l'étranger autrement dit pour les mêmes
cotisations en France la retraite est
moins élevée cette rupture d'égalité se
trouverait encore renforcée si le myco
était augmenté de 25 euros et si le
micro majoré était augmenté 75 euros
comme le prévoit le présent projet de
loi comment faire pour que les
Françaises et Français étrangers avec
une retraite française faible puisse
toucher le micro le plafond de
1322,87 euros pour être abaissé en
fonction du nombre de trimestres cotisés
en France autrement dit au lieu d'un
plafond absolu il faudrait un calcul
proratiser changer la méthode de calcul
du micro permettrait également aux
Françaises et Français d’étranger de
toucher l'augmentation du micro et du
micro majoré aussi cet amendement vise à
demander au Conseil d'orientation des
retraites d'établir un rapport sur les
possibilités de verser ce minimum
contributifs majorés aux personnes ayant
effectué qu'une partie de leur carrière
en France au prorata des trimestres
cotisés en France
Merci monsieur vernis avis de la
commission rapport dans ta vie
défavorable
3517 madame poncemonge
d'appel les associations et les
syndicats nous ont envoyé de nombreuses
amendements pour nous demander de
préciser par des décrets en Conseil
d'État les mesures précisément parce que
leur confiance envers les annonces du
gouvernement est entamé la parole du
gouvernement est un peu
démonétariser notamment sur cet article
10 le gouvernement écrit dans le rapport
sur les objectifs de la réforme 200000
personnes sur 800.000 à peu près chaque
année serait concerné pour les assurer
vous dites bénéficiant de la mesure pour
se bénéficiant les 200 000 la hausse
moyenne c'était belira à 400 euros par
an n'hésitez pas à le mettre en moi
c'est-à-dire à 3 3 euros par mois contre
deux ans de plus de travail vous
conviendrait que la mesure quand même
d'accompagnement est faible d'autant
plus qu'elle aurait dû avoir lieu depuis
6 ans bien alors donc nous disons que
quand au toujours la même question et
quand il quittera 100 euros parce que
c'est vrai que 100 euros c'est un peu le
chiffre fétiche et bien la consommera
1,7% des nouveaux retraités bien contre
deux ans de travail pour tous vous
conviendrez que c'est un peu faible bien
c'est à dire 13000 personnes sur toutes
les générations l'adresse quand même
s'étonne un peu d'ailleurs des chiffres
même si elle note que les seigneurs sont
particulièrement concernés par par le
SMIC elle dit moins de 10% des périodes
rémunérées au salaire minimum dure plus
de 3 ans par la suite les chiffres du
gouvernement n'ont cessé de tanguer
passant de 40000 finalement 13000
malheureusement cet épisode a fortement
nuit à la qualité des débats et à
l'information vous voyez l'information
sincère on en parlait des concitoyens et
des parlementaires ainsi il est évident
qu'une défiance se met en place et donc
cet amendement d'appel tente une
nouvelle fois de le dénoncer et de
rappeler quand même que 1,7% de toutes
les générations
toucheront le fameux 100 euros contre
deux ans de travail de plus pour
avis de la commission
merci pour tous ces commentaires qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'amendement avis
des favorable
très bien très bien allez
quatre amendements identiques le 2052
madame sologobe
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les pensions minimales telles que la
pension majorée de référence PMR pour
les non salariés agricoles vise à
valoriser la carrière de ce qui bien
qu'ayant travaillé un grand nombre
d'années nos tiennent qu'une faible
retraite notamment à cause de
rémunération peut élever au régime des
non salariés agricoles 11% des nouveaux
retraités percevaient une pension
complétée de cette fameuse PMR dans le
cas du présent projet de loi il est
prévu que lors de la liquidation de la
pension de retraite le minimum de
pension majorées myco majorée applicable
au régime aligné ne soit plus indexée
sur l'inflation mais au moins sur
l'évolution de la valeur du SMIC par
ailleurs le plafond du myco majoré est
déjà indexé sur l'évolution de la valeur
du SMIC par mesure d'équité pour les non
salariés agricoles le présent amendement
propose de transposer ces modalités de
revalorisation au montant et au plafond
de la PMR je vous remercie
ici le 2060 madame Estrosi ça sonne
que dans le cadre de cette pension
majorée de référence qui s'adresse aux
anciens actifs non salarié agricole
ayant cotisé au régime de la mutualité
sociale agricole et qui perçoivent de
faire pension tout régime ce sont les
femmes qui en sont les principales
bénéficiaires en 2022 les femmes
représentées ainsi plus de 51% des
bénéficiaires et percevaient en moyenne
un montant mensuel moyen de 123 euros au
titre de ce minima donc par cet
amendement nous souhaitons également que
ce puisse que le montant de la
majoration majorée de référence soit
revalorisée non pas sur la base de
l'évolution du SMIC mais bien sur celle
de l'inflexe sur la base de l'évolution
du SMIC et non pas sur celle de
l'inflation constatée merci le 3389
monsieur maïssoli oui monsieur le
Président c'est strictement le même il
est défendu merci le 4602
identiques madame ponce
il est défendu ah pardon
allez-y chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président
à nouveau d'un amendement de nos
collègues joël Labbé qui avait été
proposé par le gouvernement pour
atténuer la brutalité de sa réforme et
prendre en compte les non salariés
agricoles dont les retraités sont nous
le savons beaucoup trop faible avec une
moyenne inférieure au seuil de pauvreté
a fortiori pour les femmes nous l'avons
donc repris pour tenter de contribuer
dans la mesure du possible à limiter la
brutalité de cette réforme mais aussi et
surtout pour interroger le gouvernement
sur ses engagements et les éclaircir nos
prises de parole étant limitée par tous
les articles possibles du règlement cet
amendement nous donne une opportunité de
pouvoir nous exprimer sur ce sujet et
demander des clarifications
car sur ce sujet comme sur tous les
autres toutes les autres mesures
soi-disant sociales et soi-disant
correctrices des inégalités que comprend
cette réforme le contenu est flou et
laisse souvent un blanc sain au
gouvernement pour agir par décret ainsi
sur le sujet de la PMR qui est traité
par cette amendement les engagements de
revalorisation ne sont pas garanties et
sont floues pour rappel la PMR pension
majorée de référence permettent aux
retraites agricoles d'atteindre un
montant minimum minimal excusez-moi sur
le modèle du micro le texte prévoit sa
revalorisation par décret le montant
communiqué par le gouvernement étant de
100 euros soit cela est une avancée pour
les personnes concernées mais aucune
garantie n'est fixée dans la loi sur le
montant de la revalorisation
rappelons enfin concernant la sincérité
de cette réforme qu'une autre des
mesures proposées pour l'amélioration
des agriculteurs des retraites des
agriculteurs la suppression du critère
de carrière complète pour l'accès aux
85% du SMIC de la loi Chassaigne avait
été refusé par le gouvernement lors du
PLFSS pour 2023 alors que la MSA et les
syndicats agricoles y étaient favorables
ce n'est pas digne de la situation de
ces personnes merci
avis de la commission sur ces quatre
amendements identiques
pour les régimes alignés je rappelle le
régime général des indépendants et puis
des salariés agricoles et là le pendant
la PMR pour les salariés non agricoles
donc les agriculteurs si on va
revalorise les uns au niveau du SMIC on
fait de façon
identique pour les autres
avec du gouvernement favorable
favorable c'est Monsieur le Ministre le
2157 monsieur le rapporteur
un actionnelle
le
4698 qui le présente
qui le présente pardon je ferai
décidément monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
donc comme évoqué lors de la défense de
des amendements précédents à
l'initiative de niveaujeel le projet de
loi prévoit de définir le montant du
micro par décret sans consulter au
préalable des acteurs qui pourraient
apporter leur expertise et ainsi donner
des repères essentiels en complément des
amendements précédents visant à
améliorer la consultation c'est
amendement vise à transformer le décret
définissant le montant du myco en décret
en Conseil d'État cet amendement est
d'autant plus important que ces
dernières semaines ont un petit peu semé
des doutes par rapport à la gestion des
retraites je rappelle les annonces
contradictoires de la part de différents
ministres sur le nombre de personnes qui
pourraient grâce à la réforme bénéficier
d'une augmentation de leur retraite
merci
avis la commission avis de la commission
merci avis du ministre mais ma vie je
passe au 443
du groupe écologie solidarité territoire
vise à prendre le décret qui définit le
montant du minimum contributif après
consultation de la Défenseur des droits
la question du minimum vieillesse était
très sec Molière la justice lors du vote
de l'article 7 un sénateur centré sur
ses bords le rappeler ouvrez les
guillemets vous découvrez que le système
des retraites est injuste fermez les
guillaumets reprochant au bord de la
gauche de n'avoir pas agi avant tout en
reprochant aujourd'hui leur tentative
pour changer ce qui était une injustice
nous voulons agir vous le voyez et le
craignez la justice du minimum
vieillesse n'est pas certes pas
suffisant mais nécessaire l'adresse a
publié à de nombreuses reprises sur le
sujet près de quatre traités sur 10 38%
bénéficie d'un minimum de pension dans
un régime de base
cette part est toutefois plus faible
parmi les retraités les plus jeunes
après le durcissement des conditions
d'attribution depuis le 1er janvier 2012
né nouvelle règle d'attribution du
minimum contributifs ont eu pour
conséquence entre autres des retards
dans les délais de traitement dans
l'incidence et non négligeable sur la
baisse des attributions de ce minimum en
effet son versement implique le régime
concerné connaissent l'ensemble des
droits de retraites de l'assuré dans la
pratique cela n'est parfois pas le cas
ou en tout cas tardivement et de
nombreux dossiers d'attributions de
minimum contributifs pour des postures
liquidés entre 2012 et 2018 n'était
toujours pas traités en 2019
263000 dossiers nous pensons que la
vision du Défenseur des droits pourrait
aiguiller l'orientation que doit prendre
ce minimum c'est une question majeure
pour les femmes quoi qu'on en dise et
quoi qu'en disent le président et le
gouvernement leur combat pour l'égalité
salariale n'est ni suffisant ni efficace
et les conséquences de cette inaction
pèsent plus lourd sur les femmes le
ministre du sort a répété plusieurs fois
il n'y a pas de paire d'ordre bon il n'y
a pas de perdant mais je pense qu'il n'a
pas la vue complète du problème
merci
merci je vous présenterai l'amendement
suivant je pense oui monsieur le
Président
je suis obligé d'avoir la vie de la
commission c'était
monsieur le
rapporteurs qui vont suivre je vais
donner un avis global et nous pensons
que pour la revalorisation de ce minimum
contributif à 100 euros pour carrière
complète cotisée au niveau du SMIC il
n'y a pas lieu de concerter des
différents organismes dont on est sûr
dans la liste quand on oubliera certains
monsieur le ministre des favorable vous
allez quand même présenter évidemment
les amendements suivants et nous
commençons par le 444
Président vous avez lu dans mes pensées
complexe bdcer les minima de pension
répondent alors je vais primordial de
solidarité minimum contributif minimum
garanti pension minimal répandent à des
attentes légitimes de la population une
attente de dignité et aussi bien sûr
d'une certaine autonomie financière pour
nos aînés depuis 1983 ce minimum
contributif au régime général et aligné
s'applique au seul salarié partant à la
retraite à taux plein après avoir cotisé
durant leur carrière sur la base de
salaire très modeste il se distingue
cela du minimum vieillesse qui est
service sans contrepartie de cotisations
et uniquement sur des critères de niveau
de ressources du ménage à partir de 65
ans j'espère que on perçoit bien la
différence si la durée validée dans le
régime correspond à celle requise pour
une guerrière complète le minimum est
versé en entier sinon il est calculé au
prorata de la durée validée dans le
régime depuis le 1er janvier 2021 le
montant du minimum contributif s'élève à
6 25 euros 50 par mois 750 avec
majoration pour une carrière complète
vous le savez le jeu de nos discussions
est aussi celui d'une meilleure prise en
cause des situations sortant du cas dit
typique c'est à dire carrière complète
sans interruption nous trouvons que
c'est à des grands oubli de la
communication et de la construction de
cette loi dont nous voyons heureux
qu'elle ne se concentre que sur le
financement des caisses de retraite et
pas assez sur le financement des
retraites et des retraités nous le
regrettons et passant qu'avant toute
décision aussi importante que la
fixation d'un minimum de potion il
convient de prendre conseil auprès des
organismes compétents
Monsieur Bernard je pouvais présenter
puisque ils ont donné leur avis vous
avez raison 445 et le 446 vous avez
raison il y aura pas de surprises sur
les avis donc autant y aller
donc le 445
43% des agriculteurs en plus 55 ans et
plus de 210 000 devraient ainsi prendre
leur retraite dans la prochaine décennie
c'est un chiffre important la mutualité
sociale agricole qui est le régime de
protection sociale des agriculteurs a
dit regretter le report de l'âge de
départ et l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation la Confédération paysage
c'est elle aussi mobilisée contre la
réforme le mouvement de défense des
exploitants familiaux le moddef a
demandé le retrait de la réforme et à
réclamer un régime spécial pour
l'agriculture du fait de la pénibilité
de charge lourdes des astreintes des
risques liés à la manipulation des
animaux du travail au mauvais temps des
maladies professionnelles et j'en passe
même la FNSEA c'est dit inquiète avec sa
mesure habituelle de l'absence de mesure
pour gérer les fêtes carrière difficile
ainsi que de la mise en oeuvre de la
pénibilité la Confédération paysanne
dénonce une annonce tropeuse et digne
d'une escroquerie à grande échelle elle
ne concerne que les carrières complètes
à 43 autres cotisations contre 42
aujourd'hui et laisse donc de côté
toutes les carrières et complètes si les
agriculteurs c'est important alors que
le gouvernement et le président se
targue d'être à l'écoute du mode paysan
les faits sont têtus et tout comme sur
la réponse à l'urgence climatique les
actes ne sont pas à la hauteur des
horgieux mais surtout pas à la hauteur
des promesses
minima souvent repoussé explication
hasardeuse au mieux faible prise en
compte des particularités des parcours
des exploitants agricoles encore une
fois à défaut d'être écouté en amont de
la réforme les attentes écrites des
syndicats notre groupe souhaiteraient
que les textes aussi importants
ne puisse faire l'économie de la vie de
la MSA et je rajouterai monsieur le
ministre que de toute façon dans le cas
présent la discussion n'existant pas la
demande que nous vous faisons nous
espérons que vous la satisferez sans que
nous ayons besoin d'intervention plus
forte des agriculteurs
446 ah pardon monsieur le président
merci monsieur le ministre
cette hacker et qu'aux signé par
plusieurs et nombreux de mes de mes
collègues j'ai l'impression que si nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans cette situation
c'est peut-être que vous n'avez pas
essayé assez écouté écoutez les
syndicats écouter nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens mais notamment pas assez
écouté les experts et expertes sur le
sujet des retraites votre réforme est
incomprise et rejeté par une majorité de
françaises et françaises c'est
évidemment un véritable problème à
travers cet amendement je propose donc
qu'avant toute réforme de notre système
de retraite nous consultions à travers
une note spécifique notre collègue
Raymond de Poncet et je vous propose
également un titre honorifique de
remettre un Raimon de pensée un
amendement d'or pour l'ensemble de son
œuvre merci
c'était pas exactement ce qui était
écrit dans l'amendement mais on va dire
que bon allez bon vous confirmez
naturellement la vie défavorable de la
commission
deux amendements identiques qui est un
sous amendement qui vont avec le 447 qui
représente monsieur benaous
monsieur le Président certes quand on
voit la lecture et l'interprétation qui
a été fait du rapport du corps et malgré
les déclarations de son président
d'ailleurs devant la commission de
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons hésité
à proposer une telle demande d'avis pour
rappel le gouvernement base l'urgence de
la retraite sur le délabrement des côtes
alors que selon le président du corps
monsieur le ministre le site les déposes
de retraite ne dérapent pas mais elles
ne sont pas compatibles avec les
objectifs de politique économique et de
finances publiques du gouvernement et
quelles sont ses objectifs je précise
c'est à dire réaliser des économies et
réduire le déficit selon la trajectoire
budgétaire du gouvernement transmise à
la Commission européenne confortant les
premières déclarations de président
expliquant que la réforme est nécessaire
pour financer la santé l'éducation
l'avantage de dire tout et son contraire
c'est d'avoir au moins dit une fois la
vérité
pour revenir à la demande d'avis nous
avons la faiblesse de croire que
l'éclairage par des spécialistes sans
mener à un gouvernement d'experts peut
aider le décideur à prendre des
décisions et à comprendre les ressorts
de la situation le corps mi-février
c'est même poché sur le niveau de vie
des retraités et petites retraite les
chiffres montrant que le taux de
pauvreté dernièrement mesuré en 2019 qui
est la dernière année mesurée avant la
crise sanitaire et l'inflation que nous
vivons actuellement était à peu près
stable depuis les années 80 soit autour
de 10%. il nous apparaît donc évident
qu'il puisse se prononcer sur le niveau
des minimas de retraite merci le 3958
identiques oui monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce ministre
vous avez la chance qui est le 49-3
sénatorial parce que sur l'article 10 je
pense autrement que ça serait un autre
débat sur les 1200 euros que ce que nous
avons maintenant puisque nous pouvons à
peine des femmes aux amendements vous ne
répondez pas et on ne pourra pas vous
répondre à la réponse que vous faites
pas d’ailleurs mais tout le monde a cru
sur le ministre au début que ça serait
1200 euros pour tout le monde y compris
les retraites actuels et moi je veux
rendre hommage d'abord au journaliste
qui ont fait un gros travail d'enquête
et un économiste qui s'appelle Michael
Zemmour et qui a mis en lumière
en fait ce que vous étiez en train de
faire et le deuxième c'est le travail
parlementaire de notre collègue député
Jérôme Guedj qui a agi et qui a aussi
démontré et d'ailleurs moi je pense que
au moment où nous sommes il faut se dire
qu'il faut et renforcer le pouvoir
des contre-pouvoirs et notamment des
journalistes notamment qui sont entravés
avec le SCRI des affaires et renforcer
le pouvoir des parlementaires face à un
pouvoir exécutif pour que nous soyons
des gars et légal ce qu'on ne fait pas
aujourd'hui y compris avec le 49.3
sénatorial donc monsieur le ministre
ça sera 20 000 personnes qui toucheront
1200 euros sur 800000 Retraités chaque
année voilà la réalité et sur le reste
il y aura pas plus parce que une réforme
qui fait 17 milliards d'économies ce
n'est pas vrai qu'il y aura des gagnants
il n'y aura au final que des perdants
que des perdants et les 30 euros en
moyenne de revalorisation seront de
toute façon manger par l'inflation par
le prix alimentaire ou par le prix de
l'énergie et notamment celui du gaz
parce qu'autre en juin il y aura plus
tarif réglementé et tout sera sur le
marché dont même les 30 tours en moyenne
seront déjà avalés voilà la réalité
merci Monsieur gay
un sous-amendement 4960 madame Lubin
effectivement
bon telle repas sur l'objet de la main
parce que quand on connaît le
fonctionnement du corps bon se rend
compte que c'est pas tout à fait enfin
que le corps travaille sur déjà sur de
très nombreuses choses et que finalement
une expertise là-dessus ça n'est pas
vraiment son rôle mais le débat qui a
soulevé Fabien gay nous ne pourrons pas
la voir effectivement aussi bien que
nous l'aurions eu sur les 1260 euros
mais aussi sur le coup de cette réforme
des retraites
c'est bien dommage quand même qu'on
puisse pas en parler parce que cette
réforme des retraites qui est faite
initialement pour économiser 18
milliards d'euros mais on sait pas
vraiment
combien elle va coûter parce qu'elle va
coûter elle donnera peut-être quelques
économies mais nous n'avons pas accès
aux documents qui seraient nécessaires
et qui nous permettrait de savoir
exactement ce qu'elle coûtera mais nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
merci avis de la commission sur les deux
amendements et le sous amendement
il me semble que je vais
merci
avis du gouvernement défavorable
le 2429 monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre avant d'aller sur
l'objet de l'amendement comme on ne peut
pas faire d'explication de vote je
reviens sur la réponse que vous avez
apporté à notre collègue Catherine
Concorde au sujet du chlore des codes
vous avez laissé entendre si j'ai bien
compris que le sujet de santé publique
allait rapidement s'estomper puisque
l'insecticide est aujourd'hui interdit
je comprends parfaitement que vous ne
puissiez pas être avoir une cause
essence exhaustive sur tous les sujets
alors j'en profite pour vous apporter
quelques éléments le chlore des cônes
fait partie des polluants organiques
persistants avec une grande stabilité
physique et chimique vous pouvez trouver
tous ces éléments dans le rapport de
notre collègue Catherine procacia
et vous apprendrez que le chlordécone a
une rémanence de 7 siècles excusez du
peu ça veut dire que les problèmes de
santé ne vont pas s'estomper dans les
années à venir donc c'était juste pour
votre gouverne mais je vais revenir sur
l'amendement sur le sujet de la retraite
à 1200 euros autant je comprends que sur
les pesticides vous pouvez vous puissiez
avoir quelques quelques une certaine
méconnaissance du sujet autant je pense
que sur la retraite à 1200 euros c'est
pas du tout le même tabac mais bien une
volonté de tromper c'est du genre de
publicité trompeuse je ne dis pas
mensongère mais une publicité trompeuse
vous voyez bien celle qu'on trouve sur
les grosses berlines qui vous expliquent
que vous pouvez de l'acheter à 300 euros
vous pouvez le voir avec 300 euros par
mois et puis des petites lignes une
police à en 3 qui vous indique qu'il y a
un tas de conditions et qu'en fin de
compte et bien on s'est bien moqué de
vous et que c'est
inaccessible pour vous et bien c'est
exactement la même chose sur les 1200
euros on est dans le même cas de figure
une grosse publicité trompeuse et ça
c'est quand même vraiment dommage pour
les gens qui attendent une
revalorisation de la retraite monsieur
seulement est-ce que je peux me
permettre de vous demander puisque vous
avez vous êtes premier signataire sur 4
ou 5 amendements portant sur la Linéa 29
de présente ah non c'est vous alternez
pardon pas de souci alors avis de la
commission
du gouvernement défavorable donc je
passe allons-y monsieur ferdinck le 2431
allons-y monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre pour s'assurer que le décret
qui fixera le montant du minimum qu'en
contributif soit le moins excluant il
est proposé par cette amendement de
recueillir la vie de l'Union nationale
des missions locales
l'UML représente le réseau des missions
locales au plan national la mission
locale on sait intervient dans
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
des jeunes dans tous les domaines
orientation formation emploie logement
santé mobilité citoyenneté Sport Loisirs
Culture et d'accompagnement pour aider
tous les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qui en
ont besoin à résoudre l'ensemble des
problèmes que pose leur insertion
sociale et professionnelle l'objectif de
l'émission locale et de favoriser la
concertation entre les différents
partenaires pour construire des actions
adaptées aux besoins des jeunes et aux
réalités locales toute cette démocratie
sociale et ses corps intermédiaires sont
utiles et font un travail de terrain
exemplaire il devrait être intégré à la
réflexion sur la question du minimum
contributif
si avis de la commission
du gouvernement
le 2432 monsieur Ferrier
merci monsieur le Président c'est hâte
de maintenant du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire vise à consulter
Pôle emploi avant de prendre le décret
qui définira le montant du minimum
contributif
j'aimerais si vous le permettez revenir
à nouveau sur le dispositif de cet
article dont le gouvernement a voulu se
servir pour donner l'impression que sa
réforme était équilibrée entre efforts
et progresse sociale alors qu'en réalité
c'est un projet d'économie très dur qui
comporte une mesure sociale très modérée
nous l'avons déjà dit
cette revalorisation des petites
pensions concernées par le minimum
contributif sera vraiment très limité je
vais donc aller un peu plus dans le
détail
elle sera de 0 à 100 euros selon la
durée de votre carrière et à condition
d'avoir liquidé votre pension atomes à
taux plein c'est à dire sans déconnes
20% des futurs retraités seront
concernés par une revalorisation et
celle-ci sera de
33,bruts en moyenne pour les personnes
déjà retraite environ 10% seront
concernés pour un gain de 56 euros bruts
par mois en moyenne
la plupart des personnes qui ont des
carrières complètes sont déjà au dessus
des 1200 euros et ne sont donc pas
concernés par cette revalorisation
les seules personnes qui pourront
atteindre les 1200 euros à la faveur de
ce dispositif sont celles qui étaient
déjà à 1100 euros et qui gagneront
100 euros ou à 1150 euros et qui
gagneront 50 euros
on revient donc sur ce caractère
complètement trompeur de cette affichage
qui servait vraiment à vendre votre
réforme brutale
commission
ministre
je vous en prie Monsieur Dantec merci
monsieur le Président je crois que nous
l'avons tous ni maintenant ce 1200 euros
qui a été agité a servi de l'heure un
service à masquer le fait que finalement
cette réforme s'inscrit réellement et
peut-être plus lisiblement que beaucoup
d'autres réformes depuis plusieurs
années dans une véritable lutte des
classes je crois qu'on peut avoir une
Alice totalement marxiste de ce qui est
proposé aujourd'hui je savais que ça
allait vous intéresser
très clairement il y a il y a quelques
chiffres qui nous manque alors entendons
qu'il fallait absolument d'urgence
rééquilibrée
le régime des retraites entendons que
nous avons oublié effectivement cette
basculement un des revenus du travail
vers le capital depuis 30 années ce
n'est qu'une question de salariés il y a
un chiffre monsieur le ministre qui
aurait été extrêmement intéressant à
connaître qui est que si on avait fait
une réforme uniquement sur l'âge en
augmentant la durée de cotisation pour
tout le monde sans le 64 ans qui aurait
contribué au rééquilibrage ceux qui
auraient contribué cela aurait été
plutôt les classes moyennes supérieures
voire très supérieurs or votre réforme
elle fait payer par les
salariés les plus modestes ceux dont
l'espérance de vie la plus faible ça a
été dit longuement la retraite
de ceux qui ont les meilleurs boulots
dans notre société ça s'inscrit dans une
logique qui est ancienne qui s'est mise
en place même probablement avant votre
gouvernement mais avec l'élection du
président Macron c'est ce qui a été
exacerbé et ce qui a été quelque part
industrialisé simplement le leur du 1200
euros n'a pas tenu le temps du débat et
on a remercié tous ceux qui ont permis
cet éclaircissement et à partir de là
votre réforme apparaît comme
profondément injuste participe de la
fracturation de la société française du
délitement de sa cohésion il est encore
temps de revenir en arrière
le 2433 monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le président
présenté comme une compensation à
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et comme une mesure de justice
sociale aucune donnée à ce jour n'est en
mesure d'informer sur le nombre de
personnes réellement touchées par
l'article 10
rappelons que les conditions sont très
restrictives les salariés concernés
devront justifier à la fois d'une
carrière complète à temps plein dans le
privé et d'un niveau de salaire n'ayant
jamais dépassé le SMIC de fait d'après
un rapport mandaté par le gouvernement
sur la trajectoire professionnelle de
2,5 millions de personnes pendant 21 ans
seul 48 personnes n'avaient pas dépassé
le SMIC pendant cette période
ce dispositif court le risque de ne pas
améliorer la situation en particulier
des femmes magie majoritairement touché
par la décote il n'est donc qu'un effet
d'annonce mais
on peut dire qu'on recommence à s'y
habituer
alors que l'une des dix s'assure de la
mise en oeuvre de la réglementation
d'assurance chômage et garantit le
financement de l'assurance chômage bien
entendu nous proposons par cet
amendement que son avis soit obtenu pour
définir le bon temps du minimum
contributif
en effet en reportant l'âge de départ à
la retraite vous allonger mécaniquement
la durée du chômage pour les seniors
passez l'âge de 60 ans le taux d'emploi
des seniors est de
35,5%. et de 20% après 64 ans je suis
pas le premier à vous le dire mais ce
sont les chiffres la vie de lunédique
est donc tout à fait opportun dans ces
circonstances pour avoir une meilleure
compréhension et une plus grande
visibilité puisqu'on voit bien que sur
ce projet de loi les études d'impact ont
été complètement bâclés merci monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le ministre la
vie est négatif sur l'allias de la
linéa29 oui oui alors on continue le
3500 8 qui le présente
madame ponce
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement d'appel
nous redisions tout à l'heure que la loi
Fillon en 2003 prévoyait pour une
application en 2008 je le rappelle que
le minimum pension pour une carrière
complète serait égale à 85 % du SMIC
cette disposition qui concerne qui
concerne aujourd'hui un nouveau retraité
sur 4 n'a jamais été mise en oeuvre par
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 ainsi si la
loi avait été appliquée compte tenu du
SMIC actuel ce minimum de pension
contributive devrait déjà être
aujourd'hui à 1150 et je ne parle même
pas de du coup enfin ce retard ce qu'il
a coûté à plusieurs
à des dizaines de milliers de de
pensionnés et ce qui va coûter en
dizaines d'euros bien sûr restez toute
une carrière complète au SMIC je dirais
c'est une fiction statistique
pas tout à fait irréel mais statistiques
ou du moins c'est une anomalie
scandaleuse je rappelle que le SMIC en
France est censé définir un salaire
minimum sans qualification bon et sans
ancienneté c'est à dire qu'on ne reste
pas au SMIC c'est l'idée c'est l'esprit
du SMIC
de plus et de fait très peu de salariés
font une carrière complète au SMIC ça a
été dit ou c'est le ça le sera du groupe
d'experts qui je crois est très proche
très proche conseil du gouvernement mais
aussi de la DARES alors là pas
susceptible d'être
critiqué parmi les personnes ayant
effectué des périodes au salaire minimum
entre 1995 et 2015 aucune n'y est resté
plus de 12 ans alors qui se la vise mais
puisque le gouvernement sûrement faire
fournir le geste de majoré de Miko nous
vous proposons d'aller jusqu'au SMIC net
qui a comment peut-on vivre sous le
salaire minimum y compris quand on est
retraité merci Madame est-ce que vous
présentez le suivant le 3510 non
pardon 359
c'est qui monsieur ferick tout à fait
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cet amendement est également un
amendement d'appel
l'augmentation du minimum contributif
promise par le gouvernement n'améliorera
pas la situation de retraité qui non
seulement devront attendre l'âge
d'annulation de la décote pour partir à
taux plein mais subiront quand même des
revenus insuffisants pour insuffisants
pour une vie digne le minimum
contributif n'est en effet même pas
indexé sur le SMIC et la valorisation
promise n'est que 22 euros n'est que de
22 euros supérieurs au seuil de pauvreté
ce qui est très insuffisant pour
subvenir aux besoins de base pour une
retraite descente il faudrait une
indexation sur le SMIC c'est aussi une
question d'égalité en effet les femmes
sont 52% à percevoir une pension
inférieure à 1000 euros contre 20% des
hommes si la pension moyenne des hommes
et de 1931 euros par mois c'est le des
femmes n'est que de 1154 une vie de
travaille au SMIC doit ouvrir droit à
une retraite digne monsieur le ministre
qui pourrait soutenir le contraire
le 3510 maintenant madame ponce
alors j'ai senti
un peu je crois quand j'ai demandé à ce
que le minimum contributif soit au SMIC
je voudrais préciser que c'est en lien
avec la SPA que on souhaite porter au
seuil de pauvreté parce que l'écart
entre minimum retraite et minimum
contributif serait tout à fait dans ce
cas conséquente et je sais que c'est une
préoccupation de la droite les cars bien
entendu par la retraite contributive au
niveau du SMIC alors
cet article souhaite prévoit
effectivement une revalorisation du myco
mais
outre quelle est malheureusement trop
restreinte qui concerne plus de monde on
l'a vu qu'en est-il des Outre-mer il
faut que des retraités des territoires
d'outre-mer puissent bénéficier du
minimum contributif Miko nous le
demandons dès 80 trimestres cotisés soit
20 ans il s'agit là d'appliquer les
principes constitutionnels d'égalité et
de différenciation car le principe
constitutionnel d'égalité ne s'entend
pas par rapport au moyen mis en oeuvre
ça s'entend par rapport à l'objectif en
train c'est pas un contrat de moyen
c'est un contrat d'objectif
or dans les territoires d'outre-mer l'on
constate un contexte économique et
social défavorable bien sûr des
carrières hachées et un taux de pauvreté
bien supérieur et on connaît les
chiffres dont par exemple un tiers des
personnes en Guadeloupe à titre
d'exemple une étude de lycée datant de
2000 confirme que les conditions de
convoiter sont plus fortes que trois
personnes sur 10 sont un niveau de vie
inférieure à 950 euros par mois 800 aux
Antilles donc le principe de
différenciation implique d'adapter les
normes aux réalités spécifiques des
différents territoires or le nombre de
trimestres requis par les textes actuels
120 ne permet pas à nos concitoyens des
Outre-mer ayant pourtant travaillé toute
leur vie mais ayant des carrières
hachées de bénéficier d'une retraite
descente il faudrait savoir et je pose
la question aux ministres qu'on ne peut
prévoir de spécifiques pour elle et pour
eux je vous remercie
si le 3511 monsieur benaroche
alors cet amendement s'inscrit dans la
lignée des précédents ce sont donc des
amendements didactel et en l'occurrence
nous souhaitions mettre un focus très
particulier sur le cas de personnes en
situation de handicap
consulter pour avis à proposer à propos
de ce projet de loi le Conseil de la
Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie le CNSA a mis un avis très
défavorable
non pas à l'amendement mais au projet de
loi et à l'article du projet de loi
gouvernemental parmi les causes
annoncées les mesures qui concernent les
personnes en situation de handicap pour
rappel voici la position du collectif
handicap qui recouvre la plupart des
associations spécialisées ouvrez les
guillemets
le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite va aggraver la précarisation de
tous les travailleurs qui ne bénéficient
pas de disposition de dispositifs des
rogatoire et qui ont déjà des
difficultés d'accès à l'emploi en plus
d'avoir un impact direct sur l'état de
santé des travailleurs
il s'oppose donc à cette mesure et
appelle à une meilleure prise en compte
de la pénibilité et de la fatigabilité
dans le calcul des droits à la retraite
les travailleurs doivent pouvoir
bénéficier de la retraite sans
alternative sans attendre qu'un
surhandicap ou qu'une maladie survienne
donc préparé deux questions pour
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre que pouvez-vous
répondre à ces cas sur lesquels les
associations concernées par le handicap
plus Interpel et monsieur le ministre
que pouvez-vous leur répondre sur la
revalorisation du minimum contributif
c'est le 3512 monsieur Boyer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre et merci à ma collègue pour ces
Mons qui m'a proposé de présenter cet
amendement ceux qui me connaissent
savent mon attachement à l'esthétique et
notamment à l'esthétique de l'inutile
que les Anglais nomment souvent l'arpure
et c'est en effet un geste esthétique
inouï que de défendre des amendements
qui ne seront ni débattus ni soumis au
vote compte tenu de la censure du
gouvernement par le 44.3 donc encore une
fois merci j'aurais pu citer Baudelaire
qui proposait de transformer la laideur
en beauté et c'est vrai que la laideur
de ces manœuvres
procédurières fera peut-être la beauté
de cet amendement il s'agit d'un
amendement d'appel actuellement le myco
est articulé en deux étages avec une
base et une majoration à la différence
du micro de base la majoration
n'est-elle calculée que sur sur la base
des trimestres cotisés le législateur à
alourdi les conditions pour obtenir le
myco majoré en le limitant aux assurés
qui pouvaient justifier de 120
trimestres cotisés cette distinction est
complexe et difficile à comprendre quand
on n'est pas spécialiste on a pu le voir
même les ministres et président de la
République ont eu quelques mal avec ce
point dans la réforme comme avec les
fameux 1200 euros par ailleurs elle
pénalise certains travailleurs notamment
celles et ceux ayant perçu une pension
d'invalidité une grande partie de leur
carrière a-t-il de comparaison dans la
fonction publique il existe un seul
minimum le minimum garanti sans
distinction de base et de majoration le
présent projet de loi prévoit de
revaloriser les minimum mais en opérant
une distinction entre le minimum de base
25 euros et le minimum majoré 75 euros
nous proposons pour simplification
clarté et pour renforcer la politique de
revalorisation
du minimum contributif la création d'un
seul minimum chers collègues merci le
3513 monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le président
nous avons encore un amendement d'appel
destiné à entamer un débat sur un sujet
aussi important que le myco mais on vous
l'a dit et vous le savez il n'y aura pas
de débat vous l'avez tué avec le 44 3
nous l'avons dit il est très difficile
de répondre aux conditions fixées pour
être éligibles au dispositif du goût de
verneuvement il faut d'abord avoir
effectué une carrière complète ce qui
est très rare pour les personnes
précaires ou dont l'état de santé pose
des difficultés handicap accident
invalidité
selon la Dares en 2019 la grande
majorité des personnes ne font qu'une
année ou deux au SMIC je cite la
majorité des salariés qui ont connu un
épisode au SMIC sur la période ni son
cependant rester que de façon
transitoire les deux tiers des périodes
passées au salaire minimum non duré
qu'une seule année au plus les épisodes
de Smic les plus longs se concentrent
ainsi sur une part minoritaire de
salariés qui restent durablement
rémunéré à ce niveau en moyenne chaque
année seul 2% des salariés sont
rémunérés au salaire minimum depuis au
moins deux ans fin de la citation
on définitive parmi les personnes ayant
effectué des périodes au salaire minimum
entre 1995 et 2015 aucune n'y est restée
plus de 12 ans
par ailleurs il faut aussi avoir
travaillé à temps complet avec un revenu
équivalent au SMIC sur la risque
d'exclure un grand nombre de personnes
et notamment les indépendants
bien sûr la situation des personnes qui
restent au SMIC est graves car il reste
dans une situation de pauvreté qui n'est
pas acceptable et c'est pourquoi nous
demandons que la majoration du micro ne
soit pas à 85%, mais au niveau du SMIC
au moins mais de la même manière
pourquoi vouloir que les conditions
soient une carrière complétosmique il
faudrait pouvoir avancer vers une
pension au niveau du SMIC merci et le
3513 maintenant
qui le présente Madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président dans cet
amendement d'appel nous souhaiterions
parler des personnes en situation de
alors la hausse du minimum contributif
prévu à l'article 10
ne concerne que les personnes ayant une
carrière complète on l'a dit un salaire
moyen au niveau du SMIC or peu de
personnes en situation de handicap ont
des carrières complètes elle ne pourront
donc pas dans leur très grande majorité
bénéficier de cette mesure d'atténuation
de la brutalité de votre réforme et
basculeront souvent sur la SPA dont le
montant est inférieur au seuil de
pauvreté pour éviter une telle
précarisation il faut permettre à tous
les bénéficiaires de la location adulte
handicapé de continuer à la percevoir ou
de la de las légal de départ à la
retraite quelle que soit leur taux
d'incapacité actuellement cela n'est
possible que pour les personnes ayant un
taux de capacité égal ou supérieure à
80%. la hache 1 ayant atteint l'âge
légal de la retraite après le premier
janvier 2017 pour mettre un terme à
cette injustice il faudrait supprimer
l'obligation des bénéficiaires de la
question adulte handicapé 2
bénéficiaire enfin ayant un taux
d'incapacité entre 50 et 79% de basculer
vers la SPA lors de la liquidation
l'endroit à la retraite c'est inégalité
de traitement crée effectivement des
disparités monsieur le ministre
envisagez vous d'avancer vers ces
dispositions et là j'espère que une
réponse du moins par respect pour les
personnes concernées car n'ayant pas la
possibilité de vous répondre ensuite par
une explication de vote vote de toute
façon vous pouvez pas me respecter
merci le
3515 maintenant je suis le président
monsieur le Président alors que le
Président de la République refuse
fermement de recevoir les syndicats
alors que vous vous entêtez dans la
proximation et la justice alors que vous
refusez le débat même au Parlement plus
personne ne comprend rien qui touchera
1200 euros on le voit bien pas grand
monde et pourtant vous avez fait espérer
terriblement déçu de nombreuses
personnes nous avons besoin de vérité et
de sincérité et à travers cette
amendement de Raymond de Poncet nous
souhaitons évoquer la question des
retraités pauvres puisque c'est le sujet
de l'article 10 et cela aurait pu
enrichir les débats que nous n'avons pas
le minimum contributif je ne vous
apprends rien permet au retraités du
régime général de l'assurance vieillesse
de la sécurité sociale qui ont cotisé
sur de faibles salaires de percevoir un
montant minimum de retraite de base
appelée minimum contributifs si l'assuré
présente au moins 120 trimestre cotisée
ce minimum contributif est de
8970,87 € brut par an soit
747,57 euros brut par mois si l'assuré
est présente moins de 120 trimestres
cotisés au régime général le montant du
minimum contributif est fixé à 820962
euros brut par an soit
684,14 euros brut par mois le problème
est vous le savez que l'attribution se
minimum contributif ne peut pas porter
le total des pensions de retraite
au-delà du plafond mensuel des retraites
personnelles la complexité des
dispositifs peut peut-être nous amener à
imaginer une règle simple et on en a
bien besoin à savoir que le minimum
contributif soit fixé au niveau du seuil
de pauvreté établi par l'INSEE à hauteur
de 60% du niveau de médian
soit actuellement 1100 euros donc c'est
vrai que monsieur le ministre c'est
dommage que vous nous écoutiez pas mais
je pense que c'est quelque chose sur
lequel vous auriez pu réfléchir en tout
cas j'espère qu'à un moment donné vous
allez quand même nous donner quelques
petites réponses parce que c'est vrai
que c'est bien de museler le Parlement
mais vous pouvez faire aussi un effort
pour nous donner quelques explications
et pourquoi vous n'aviez pas retenu
l'ensemble de ces amendements merci
3516 Monsieur Dantec
et merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement nous rappelle
l'existence du fonds de réserve pour les
retraites créant 1990 le fond de réserve
pour les retraites est un été blessure
public d'État qui avait justement pour
mission principale de gérer les sommes
qui lui étaient affectés afin de
constituer des réserves destinées à
contribuer à la pérennité des régimes de
retraite il avait vocation à faire
fructiver ses ressources en vue
d'assurer le financement de la bosse
démographique à partir de 2020 donc nous
savions dès le départ que nous aurions
des difficultés en début de décennie
depuis 2011 et comme corrélé à la loi
allonzant l'âge légal qui en reprend
directement l'objet la loi disposée
jusqu'en 2024 le fond vert chaque année
2,1 milliards d'euros à la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale dans
le même temps c'est ça le problème on
Atari son alimentation la suppression la
plupart des sources d'amendement du FFR
a mis à l'arrêt l'augmentation de ses
fonds propres qui avant que la loi verse
n'intervienne aurait dû atteindre entre
65 milliards environ 65 milliards et
aurait ainsi permis de rembourser les
déficits successifs de la destinée
actuelle et de sa fameuse Bose
démocratique ce à quoi se réserve était
initialement destiné il en a aujourd'hui
que 36 et nous sommes face à donc cette
annonce d'un nouvel allongement de l'âge
légal c'est l'occasion de revenir
rapidement sur la réforme verse rappelez
qu'à l'époque mais je pense que Rivers
apparaîtrait aujourd'hui comme un
dangereux gauchiste la réforme avait
même
mis sur la table d'autres contributions
que les cotisations et l'allongement de
la retraite avait mis une cotisation des
stocks options avait mis une surtax sur
un l'immobilier et que donc en 2010 mais
vous n'avez plus effectivement monsieur
le ministre ces réflexes gauchistes vous
assumez une vision ultralibérale
beaucoup plus claire au moins là-dessus
vous êtes clair à l'époque on
considérait quand même que l'équilibre
du régime passait par une contribution
non seulement des salariés mais aussi du
capital merci Monsieur Dantec le
3517 maintenant qui le présente oui oui
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues
cet amendement vise à prendre le décret
qui définira le montant du minimum
contributif après consultation de la
caisse de retraite
de prévoyance et de retraite de la
Société nationale des chemins de fer
français c'est d'ailleurs l'occasion
aussi de parler de la suppression dans
ce projet de loi dans certains nombre de
régime spéciaux ou autonomes y compris
d'ailleurs celui de la SNCF
au cas dialogue social n'a été mené ni
n'est prévu et les légitimes
revendications des salariés de la SNCF
concerné par la fin brutale d'une des
clauses de leur engagement dans le
métier n'est prévu les organisations
syndicales divergent sont déjà exprimées
leur opinion sans que vous les écoutiez
mais bien entendu vous allez le faire
maintenant puisque Emmanuel Macron va
les recevoir je vous rappelle quand même
monsieur le ministre que la
Confédération générale du travail a
expliqué que ces systèmes particuliers
participent à l'attractivité de
profession qui peine à recruter c'est
très bien qu'elle peine encore plus à
recruter en ce moment selon Catherine
Perret secrétaire confédéral de la CGT
en charge des retraites les régimes
dispession de retraite sont des régimes
pionniers en matière de droit à la
retraite ils sont juste et adaptés à
l'organisation du travail dans ces
secteurs
un autre syndicat solidaire a expliqué
que les salariés devront d'obtenir deux
ordres plus jusqu'à leur départ anticipé
subissent en traitement médico arrêt
maladie voire inaptitude les salariés
vont arriver en moins bon état de santé
à la retraite qu'aujourd'hui Force
Ouvrière de son côté pour qui cette
nouvelle case sociale après la réforme
verte dont a parlé Ronan dans terre qui
a déjà allongé deux ans la retraite en
fonction publique et les résidus
spéciaux est-il acceptable nous vous
demandons donc par cet abonnement de
prendre le décret qui définira le
montant du minimum contributif après
consultation de la Caisse de prévoyance
et de retraite de la SNCF
merci le 3518
le 3518
mais la vie du gouvernement et la vie de
la commission était donnée au début sur
l'ensemble de la liasse sur la ligne A
d'accord oui merci monsieur le Président
c'est pour ça qu'il discute entre eux
ils ont plus rien à écouter bien alors
cet amendement vise effectivement à
prendre le décret qui définira le
montant du minimum contributif après
consultation de la caisse de retraite du
personnel de la région autonome des
transports parisiens dit RATP je rassure
consultation pas négociation ça va voilà
donc consultation vous savez faire donc
il faut le faire parce que moi je trouve
nous les avons entendu en audition que
cette caisse de retraite du personnel de
la RATP avait une forte expertise ont
une forte expertise et je crois que ils
peuvent tout autant l'apporter
l'amener pour justement
ce minimum contributif pour en discuter
parce qu'ils nous ont justement dit que
on dit la RATP c'est 75% ils sont comme
les fonctionnaires ils ont 75% de leur
retraite sur X mois etc non actuellement
c'est 65% le taux de remplacement à la
RATP et parce que effectivement comme
tout le monde il n'y a pas simplement
l'âge il y a aussi la décote voilà ça
éviterait beaucoup de mensonges si on
disait un petit peu la réalité des
chiffres et c'est une caisse en plus non
seulement qui a une forte expertise qui
sait de quoi elle parle quelquefois moi
je doute voilà
et qui gérait avec c'est un organisme
indépendant nous sommes bien d'accord
avec une particulière efficience quand
même cette caisse je voulais dire parce
que l'efficience est une partie de
l'expertise qui serait un milliard deux
de prestations avec 40 personnes oui
pour 52000 pensionnés et 42000 salariés
donc et des frais de gestion de 0,4%
voilà une qualité de service plus plus
donc
ceci pour dire que je pense que les
consultés sur ça c'est consulté des
experts c'est consulter des gens qui
savent de quoi il parle merci le 3519
Monsieur dossu Merci monsieur le
Président donc je vais pas céder au
mélangeionniste de mon collègue Dantec
mais tout de même je vais quand même
dire que je suis d'accord avec vous
chers collègues sur le fait que cette
réforme s'inscrit dans une forme de
lutte des classes
et en réalité évidemment les 1200 euros
sont à l'heure et plus les Français ont
compris que c'était un leurre et plus
ils sont rejoint les mobilisations parce
que les Français sont très très attachés
à l'égalité et ils sont aussi attachés à
la probité des ministres et plus entendu
les mensonges notamment de ceux qui ont
dit que c'est 1200 euros seraient un
plancher une retraite plancher et plus
ils ont compris que c'était un mensonge
et plus ils ont compris que cette
retraite cette réforme était injuste
mais vos ministres continuent de mentir
votre punisse de des relations au
Parlement viennent Twitter qu'on pouvait
défendre nos amendements en réalité on
peut à peine les présenter quand on a la
vie on ne peut pas les défendre donc
faut qu'il arrête de raconter tout ce
qui raconte parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
ouvre la bouche il raconte des bêtises
je vais revenir sur le côté inégalitaire
s'il vous si vous le permettez de cette
réforme en 2015 la France comptait 800
2000 personnes âgées pauvres vivants
avec moins de 1000 euros par mois en
2015 800 2000 aujourd'hui ils sont près
de 5 millions de seniors à vivre avec
moins de 1000 euros par mois un tiers
des retraités perçoit moins de 1000
euros selon le rapport parlementaire sur
les petites pensions des députés Lionel
cos et Nicolas turquois en 2021 nos
aînés représentent 10% des personnes
pauvres mais leur situation ne
s'améliore pas
et on n'est pas moins grave de l'autre
côté les néons retraités les
multimillionnaires profitent de leur
retraite quelques exemples de grands
patrons qui ont pris leur retraite ces
derniers mois Antoine Frérot Veolia 64
ans Jean-Paul Agon L'Oréal 65 ans Benoît
potier et Air Liquide 64 ans
Pierre-André chalandendar Saint-Gobain
63 ans on voit bien que les inégalités
continueront et ce n'est pas les 1200
euros pour uniquement mille 13000
d'entre eux qui qui résoudra les
problèmes je vous remercie merci
sur quelle base
c'est sur le sur les travaux
pas sur la situation alors je vous en
prie
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre et la
présidente de la commission font des
conversations alors ça arrive dans tous
nos débats mais là c'est manifestement
le mépris il y a aucune écoute de toute
une série d'amendements présentés par
nos collègues alors non seulement on
nous empêche de débattre non seulement
le président de la République veut par
recevoir les syndicats non seulement on
part des méthodes cumulatives parce que
c'est quand même rare de cumuler elle
fait qu'on puisse pas parler à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'on limite le
temps qu'on utilise le 44
alinéa 3 et en même temps un mépris
profond profond pour ce qui est dit par
nos collègues alors déjà il y a pas de
réponse mais en plus il écoute même pas
donc franchement moi je demande au
ministre d'avoir au moins la correction
d'écouter la présentation des
amendements ce que beaucoup de collègues
font
merci allez on va reprendre la série
d'amendements là alors j'en étais où là
allez 4584 le président comptable en
avance c'est votre série d'amendements
en plus franchement bon c'est le dernier
que j'accepte ce soir franchement ça
suffit non non parce que la Conférence
des Présidents a dit qu'il ne devait pas
y avoir de rappel le règlement sur 44
bis et la conférence de président Dupas
sur le règlement c'est un dossier de
droit le rappelle au règlement donc je
vois pas la conférence
vous ne pouvez pas contester les
décisions de la conférence du président
qui se passe moi je veux bien ok on a
totalement muselé à la fois notre notre
droit d'amendement de droit de débat on
a on a un ministre mais faut y aller ça
me dérange pas on a un ministre du coup
qui ne participe plus on a une
commission qui ne participe plus et puis
là je vois un tweet du ministre chargé
de relations avec avec le gouverneur
avec le parlementaires
le débat va continuer au Sénat avec une
discussion de fond sur le texte chaque
sénateur pourra défendre ses amendements
puis il aura un vote à la fin du texte
c'est l'instruction qui aurait mis fin
au débat je pense que le président
ça n'est pas un rappel aux règlements
non non
vous savez parfaitement la distinction
entre une réponse politique et le
fonctionnement de notre assemblée merci
monsieur le Président Gontard on vous a
écouté mais je n'accepterai plus de
rappel le règlement politique je suis
désolé c'est le fonctionnement du Sénat
non non
c'est lequel le 4584 monsieur Fernique
et on reprend le cours des choses oui
monsieur le Président voyez-vous
monsieur le ministre si vous prenez
l'article 10 à son alinéa 29 et après le
mot décret vous insérez les mots pris
après avis des chambres de métiers de
l'artisanat et bien ça permettrait de
garantir davantage de dialogue social
le
4693 qui le défend oui monsieur dessus
oui merci monsieur le Président mais
donc
cette réforme des retraite est quand
même assez problématique il y a de
multiples égards et notamment dans sa
procédure on le voit bien là on le voit
bien ce soir
et les problèmes sont double ils portent
à la fois sur les débats au Parlement et
la mise en oeuvre de la réforme est-ce
que nous vivons c'est vraiment une
limitation préoccupante de nos droits
d'opposition cela a été dit et redit et
redit le gouvernement a utilisé avec un
véhicule législatif déjà très limitatif
empêchant les deux chambres de discuter
au fond et si ce n'est pas déjà assez la
droite sénatoriale ces derniers jours ne
s'est pas gêné d'abuser des dispositions
du règlement intérieur pour écourter les
débats encore davantage et pour empêcher
la discussion au fur et à mesure qu'on
approchait de dimanche soir avec
l'activation de l'article 42 qui a
limité grandement le nom d'intervention
et puis la mise en cause régulière de
notre droit d'amendement
avec des nombreuses sous amendements qui
ont été déclarés irrecevables sur
l'article 7 et puis aujourd'hui ce soir
le 44 3 qui a rendu nos débats
extrêmement peu pertinents
mais il y a un autre sujet problématique
sur la procédure à de nombreux points le
projet loi prévoit de procéder par voie
décret et oublie tout simplement de
consulter les acteurs qui connaissent au
mieux les réalités du terrain du monde
du travail en plus d'ignorer les
milliers de Françaises et Français
opposés à la réforme en plus ignorer
l'opposé l'opposition franche de
syndicats les auteurs de ce projet de
loi négligent le rôle des acteurs qui
connaissent le mieux le monde du travail
il est ainsi pour la définition du
montant minimum contributif le fameux
micro
son montant peut être augmenté par des
Crêts mais ne prévoit aucune
consultation préalable c'est pourquoi le
groupe écologiste demande à ce que le
Myco ne puisse être augmenté qu'après
consultation du Conseil national des
politiques de lutte contre la pauvreté
et l'exclusion sociale merci le 4694 qui
le présente
le Haut Conseil de la famille est un
organisme consultatif placé sous
l'autorité de la première ministre il
est un successeur du comité
interministériel et le Haut Comité
consultatif lui crée après la Libération
le Haut Conseil de la famille visa
conseiller le gouvernement sur les
questions démographiques sur tout sur le
long terme sa mission est notamment
d'apporter au pouvoir public une
expertise une expertise prospective et
transversale sur les questions liées à
la famille à l'enfance à l'avancée en
âge à l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement et à la bien traitance
dans une approche intergénérationnelle à
ce titre il devrait être entendu lors
des discussions sur le montant du micro
aussi cet amendement visa spécifié que
le montant du minimum contributif ne
pourra être défini sans consultation du
Haut Conseil de la famille
merci le
4695 merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à spécifier qu'une
augmentation du micro ne pourra pas se
faire par simple décret ce qui risque de
passer outre les différentes réalités de
terrain en particulier cet abandon vise
à ce que le montant du minimum
contributif ne puisse être défini sans
consultation du comité national
consultatif des personnes handicapées la
prise en compte de son avis est en effet
essentielle car notre régime de retraite
de retraite ne tient pas suffisamment
compte des situations de personnes en
situation de handicap dont le parcours
est trop difficile et se met de nombreux
obstacles rappelons que le taux de
chômage des personnes en situation de
handicap et 6 points au dessus de celui
de la moyenne de la population alors
qu'il est de 8% pour l'ensemble de la
population il est de 14% pour les
personnes en situation de handicap de
plus les personnes en situation du
handicap ont souvent une retraite faible
ce qui est entre autres le résultat du
fait qu'elles ont des carrières hachées
une fois arrivé à l'âge de la retraite
elle se retrouve beaucoup
souvent en situation de pauvreté le taux
de pauvreté des retraités en situation
de handicap ou de perte d'autonomie est
nettement nettement supérieur à celui
des autres retraités alors que 8% des
retraités sont pauvres selon les
derniers chiffres de l'adresse 12,7% des
personnes en situation de handicap ou en
perte d'autonomie le son c'est injuste
et c'est un exemple de plus qu'il est
urgent de lutter contre la pauvreté dans
notre pays dans le contexte de cette
urgence c'est un moment propose à ce que
le décret définissant le montant du
minimum contributif soit pris en compte
avec l'avis du comité national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
merci le 4696 monsieur Fernique oui
monsieur le Président chers collègues
monsieur le ministre cet amendement vise
à ce que le montant du myco ne puisse
être laissé à la seule discrétion du
gouvernement qui risque d'ignorer les
réalités les parcours des personnes
concernées mais demandent à ce que le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes soient consultés
pour avis il s'agit en effet de limiter
la casse rappelons que ce projet de loi
est en effet profondément injuste pour
les femmes qui sont impactées de manière
disproportionnée par de nombreuses
dispositions de cette réforme ce n'est
pas moi qui le dit mais le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement Franck
Riester je me permets de vous rappeler
qu'à l'antenne de Public Sénat monsieur
Riester disait je cite que les femmes
sont un peu pénalisées et un peu plus
impactés que les hommes par cette
réforme fermer les guillemets sous
l'impact de cette réforme les femmes ne
vont travailler 9 mois de plus alors que
les hommes ne devront travailler que
cinq mois de plus 60% des économies
médias liées au décalage de l'âge de
départ portent sur les femmes et ce
alors que l'écart des pensions entre les
pensions de droit direct et de 39%
citez-moi une personne qui trouverait
cela juste qui peut approuver une
réforme qui demande aux femmes de
travailler plus longtemps alors qu'elles
sont moins bien payées que les hommes
pourquoi de tels écarts la réponse est
assez simple les femmes ont souvent des
carrières hachées dans les couples ce
sont souvent les femmes qui s'occupent
des enfants de la famille du ménage ce
sont les femmes qui font le travail du
prendre soin on dit du Caire or à chaque
moment qu'elles font le travail du
prendre soin elle ne cotise pas pour
leur retraite mais grâce à elle les
hommes peuvent aller travailler et eux
ils cotisent bien sûr c'est comme cela
qu'à la fin de la carrière on se
retrouve avec de telles inégalités
inacceptables entre les niveaux des
retraites des femmes et des hommes il
faut alors prendre des mesures pour
éviter que ces inégalités ne se creusent
encore plus merci le 4697
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
dernier abonnement écrit par ma collègue
Mélanie Vogel qui nous dit que le
problème des politiques publiques et
qu'elles ont un biais de gens alors
qu'elles sont trop souvent conçues par
et pour les hommes elles ne prennent
guère en compte les situations
auxquelles peuvent être exposées les
femmes trop souvent elles sont adaptées
à un parcours type qui est celui d'un
homme sans tenir compte de celui des
femmes au mieux des adaptations sont
faites à la marge pour mieux y répondre
dans ce cas spécifique il convient
d'être vigilant sur les conditions de
définition de définition du mico d'après
la CNAV 80% des bénéficiaires du mycose
sont des femmes
80%, c'est le résultat du fait que les
femmes ont plus souvent des carrières
hachées et ont en moyenne des salaires
moins élevés
elles ont donc plus souvent des
retraites très faibles en raison pour
laquelle elles sont éligibles au micro
il convient donc de veiller à ce que les
perspectives des bénéficiaires donc
majoritairement des femmes soient prises
en compte au mieux en complément de
l'amendement précédent défendu par mon
collègue Jacques fernik c'est amendement
vise à ce que le montant du Miko ne
puisse être laissé à la seule discrétion
du gouvernement qui risque d'ignorer les
réalités et les parcours des personnes
concernées mais demande à ce que la
fédération nationale solidarité femme
soit consultée pour avis
merci je rappelle que sur l'ensemble des
amendements de Leia 29 la vie du
gouvernement et la vie de la commission
sont défavorables le 2911 c'est Monsieur
le testeur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue c'est un
amendement vice à prévoir que le décret
fixant la majoration du minimum
contribue-t-il pour les personnes déjà à
la retraite soit pris après avis du
comité d'orientation des retraites
pourquoi cela monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre parce que chien
échaudé craint l'eau froide et que nous
avons vu tellement d'imprécisions malgré
les jours et les nuits de débat moi je
pense encore à des personnes que j'ai
rencontrées aujourd'hui et qui me disait
mais nous allons toucher 1200 euros
minimum
elles en étaient persuadées mais je leur
ai dit mais enfin il était question de
cela il y a un certain temps mais on
nous a dit après que c'était 40 000
personnes seulement et puis on nous a
dit que c'était 20 000 personnes et puis
on n'est même pas sûr aujourd'hui que ce
soit 20 000 personnes autrement dit il y
a quand même une sorte de mépris dans
cette imprécision constante ce pourquoi
nous demandons des précautions et nous
avons bien raison de les demander parce
que nous n'avons pas eu les réponses que
nous devions attendre sur des points
essentiels de ce projet de loi et je
dois dire que je suis quelque peu frappé
par la différence atmosphère qui existe
en cette enceinte entre hier et
aujourd'hui il s'est passé quelque chose
ce matin me suis dit en arrivant en
effet l'utilisation du 44 3 a pour effet
qu'il n'y a plus de réponse plus de
contradictions plus d'explications de
vote et plus de vote donc d'une certaine
façon on Annie il ma chère collègue ce
qui fait l'intérêt le charme la force et
la profondeur du Sénat monsieur le
Président je vous remercie c'est avis de
la commission
avis de la commission
toujours le même avis par rapport à
toutes ces demandes de consultation
avant de prendre un décret merci
monsieur le ministre de prendre vos
décrets plus rapidement qu'en attendant
les 25 ou 30 consultations qui pendant
ce temps-là retarde de Ré la revers les
réalisations des petites pensions
le 4583 qui le défend monsieur Ferny
merci monsieur le Président oui dans
j'ose pas dire dans la même lignée mais
je vais essayer que le la précédente
défense de Monsieur le Kester
jean-Pierre Sueur cet amendement demande
une précaution de plus pour les chiens
échaudés et que le décret les chiens il
a dit les chiens il a dit les chiens ils
demandent que le décret soit pris après
consultation des chambres d'agriculture
allez on laisse avancer ça sert à rien
de retarder sinon on finira jamais allez
merci
j'ai dit merci allez allez rester sur
votre amendement et avançons
je regrette parce que le président mais
j'avais fini alors c'est parfait
négatives du gouvernement négatif oui
d'accord allez
2158 rédactionnelles monsieur
un amendement d'une grande importance je
me permettrai de présenter les deux
suivant trois amendements rédactionnels
pour les humains
madame force
alors les règles peut-être ne
s'appliquent plus aujourd'hui vous avez
peut-être nous permettre des appels aux
règlements bien le présent amendement se
propose de demander un rapport évaluant
le nombre de bénéficiaires concernés
intégralement par la revalorisation de
la pension minimale la portant à 85% du
SMIC je crois que c'est vraiment
important parce que là il y a une
démonétisation de la parole du
gouvernement là-dessus il faut être il
faut quand même résoudre ça et il nous
faut un rapport quand même je pense que
c'est important alors on l'a dit la
grande majorité des personnes ne font
qu'une année ou deux au SMIC enfin
normalement les épisodes de Smic dit la
DARES les plus longs se concentrent
ainsi sur une part minoritaire de
salariés qui reste durablement rémunéré
à ce niveau en moyenne dit la DARES
chaque année seul 2% des salariés sont
rémunérés au salaire minimum depuis au
moins deux ans donc on voit pas très
bien comment semico a même encore
13000 bénéficiaires enfin ou 40 000 vues
cela si l'on se enfin la revalorisation
si l'on se concentre sur les épisodes
passés au voisinage du salaire minimum
c'est-à-dire les intervalles de temps
caractérisé pour les individus sur une
période donnée par une ou plusieurs
années consécutives aux alentours du
SMIC les deux tiers d'entre eux n'ont du
nom de durée qu'une seule année ou plus
moins de 10% des Périers des périodes
rémunérées au salaire minimum dure plus
de trois ans il y a quand même une chose
importante là et qui nous intéresse
compte tenu de ce qu'on a dit sur le sas
de précarité qui est vraiment peut-être
la conséquence sociale la plus
gravissime ces gens qui vont rester dans
le sas de précarité deux ans le risque
de se maintenir durablement autour du
niveau de rémunération minimum se fait
davantage sentir après 50 ans et depuis
et oui alors à moins que vous fassiez le
4000 attendez d'avoir ravi de la
commission avis de la commission c'est
favorable avis du gouvernement
c'est vous qui faites non le 4600 c'est
Monsieur allez-y
notre collègue Joël abbé et consignée
par tout le groupe et qui propose
d'évaluer les risques de retard dans les
traitements des demandes d'attribution
du minimum contributifs liés à la mise
en place des nouvelles dispositions du
présent projet de loi d'après un rapport
de l'adresse datant de 2020 il a été
constaté que les modifications des
règles et à l'attribution du minimum
contributifs ont entraîné des retards
dans le traitement des demandes dans
l'incidence et non négligeable sur la
baisse des attributions de ce minimum en
effet sans versement applique que le
régime concerné connaisse l'ensemble des
droits à la retraite de l'assuré dans la
pratique cela n'est parfois pas le cas
ou en tout cas tardivement et de
nombreux dossiers d'attributions de
minimum contributifs pour des pensions
liquides entre 2012 et 2018 il était
toujours pas traité en 2019 c'est aussi
le constat de rapport de la cour des
côtes sur l'application des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
publié en octobre 2020 qui constate que
la grotte complexité des minimats de
potion conduit à ce corps pratique au 31
décembre 2018 le réseau d'insuffisance
de coordination entre régime de retraite
près de 2000 nombre de personnes ayant
pris leur retraite et éligible
potentiellement au minimum contributifs
servis par le régime général voient leur
dossier rester durablement suspens
situation susceptible de priver
certaines d'entre elles malgré des
versements d'accords
constituent en proportion une par
importante de revenus autre conséquence
négative pour les bénéficiaires c'est
retards peuvent donner lieu à des
avances avec une régularisation
potentielle a posteriori ainsi alors
même que le retraité concerné ne
bénéficie que de revenus très modestes
rien ne lui garantit que la voce
proposée correspond bien à ses droits et
qu'il n'aura pas à rembourser le parti
voire même l'intégralité si finalement
le droit au minimum n'est pas ouvert
c'est une source d'assécurité
supplémentaire pour des publics déjà
précaires avec votre réforme dans la
mise en oeuvre et précipitée du fait du
véhicule législatif choisi choix que
nous avons de cesse de contester on peut
craindre que ces retards soient d'autant
plus présents pénaliser encore davantage
des individus en situation de précarité
si c'est bien vide la commission
avis du gouvernement merci après
l'article 10 quoi non
sur les articles il y a pas
d'explication de vote non non parce
qu'il y a pas de vote il y a pas
d'explication de vote